[Applause]
in november 1945 war crimes trials began
in nuremberg germany for major nazi
figures the trials of 22 individuals
lasted until late 1946
for the 70th anniversary of the
nuremberg trials c-span's american
history tv is airing an oral history
interview with the former chief
prosecutor for the united states
benjamin ferenz mr ferenz was born in
transylvania to a jewish family and
immigrated to america when he was an
infant he enlisted in the u.s army after
earning his law degree and later was
assigned to set up a war crimes branch
to investigate nazi atrocities in this
interview he discusses the anti-semitism
he faced and his wartime memories of
europe
this is the first of a three-part
interview and was conducted by the
united states holocaust memorial museum
in washington dc
it's about two hours
uh tell me what your name you were born
with the name i was given as an infant
was barrel
which was the jewish name but when we
came to america
they decided that was not a suitable
name and so i was called benny
and
at that time benny leonard was a big
prize fighter name
and when i got onto school they decided
to change that then he was abbreviated
so they called me benjamin and then when
i needed a middle initial and i had none
i took b and then they had to say well
what does that stand for and so i went
back to beryl so by the time i got out
of law school i was benjamin
beryl or burrell friends
and where were you educated prior to law
school well when we came as immigrants
to the united states i was raised in new
york i went through the typical type of
new york immigrant lower east side
beginning and then
my father
got a job as a janitor
they didn't call them supers in those
days in a apartment house in hell's
kitchen over on 56th street and 10th
avenue and there's where my earliest
recollections begin
from there i went to the new york school
system the public schools my parents
were divorced when i was six so i went
out to live with an aunt who lived in
brooklyn and that's where i actually
started school
because i was
too small and i couldn't speak english
so they wouldn't take me to school until
i was seven so i was off to a slow start
i was a slow starter but my education
was primarily in new york i caught up
uh
with my education by going to townsend
harris high school which was a school
for with an accelerated curriculum and
from there i went into city college in
new york and from there i went to the
harvard law school where'd you major in
city college at city college i majored
in sociology and interestingly enough
i was always interested in crime
prevention
and
maybe that related to my early
recollections in a highly dense crime
area uh hell's kitchen if you looked at
a map of crimes in the united states
that was black because there were more
crimes committed there than any place
else and that may have stimulated my
interest in in crime prevention because
there but for the grace of might have
gone i were you an only child no i had a
sister an older sister who was 18 months
older than i
and did you both live with this aunt uh
yes when the parents were divorced they
had to find their own way fortunately
they were both remarried and they both
lived happily ever after and we all
lived happily ever after my mother and
father were related they were cousins
second cousins who were uh assigned to
marriage at birth and it didn't work out
but their subsequent marriages worked
out very well and then we all became
good friends
what made you go to law school
i always wanted to be a lawyer
i don't know where it came from and i
don't know why because i didn't know any
lawyers but somehow i always wanted to
be a lawyer
and that's why i went to law school was
there any particular interest in the law
yes i was interested in crime prevention
uh and i had no interest whatsoever in
taxation i thought i'm never going to
have any money and i'm never going to
defend anybody at a tax matter i had no
interest in corporate law
and so i was immediately involved in
criminal law
and uh did very well i won a scholarship
on that at my first exam at harvard and
then i went to work
under one of these student aid programs
for a professor of criminal law and
criminal administration professor
shelton look at how but who was the
leading authority in the field of
juvenile crime
and
that had an important influence on my
later career
when you were in college the war had
started
uh
no the war started when i was in law
school
uh i recall the uh december 7th uh and
when pearl harbor i'm talking about the
miata state's involvement in the war
the war was on in europe but
the united states involvement began when
i was at harvard
and i remember the day when everybody
went down to and to enlist
were you conscious of national socialism
what it was doing in germany prior to
going to harvard while you were oh yes i
was very much so um but
there was then a large movement to stay
out of the war during the early years
an anti-war protest movement and i think
i was more inclined to be sympathetic to
that movement uh than to anything else
there was a general awareness of the
persecution of the jews for example and
i remember
a protest rally which took place in
madison square garden i think my parents
went down there to protest and call for
a boycott against germany for the
persecution of the jews so we were aware
of that but it was only when i got into
harvard
that this professor gluck began to
receive reports of the atrocities in
poland because he had been invited by
what was then called the united nations
war crimes commission had nothing to do
with the united nations as we know it
today
uh to be the american member of that
and he funneled all of those reports to
me so i was very much aware of what had
been happening to the jews in poland
beginning in 1939 because we got those
reports 1940-41
and these are very detailed reports they
were quite detailed in terms of uh
the the size of the massacres we didn't
have you know such details as uh pulling
out gold teeth and uh you know making
mattresses out of the hair but we knew
that the jews were being rounded up and
sent to a camps where they're being
exterminated were you getting einstein's
group in replacement no i never heard
the word einsatzgruppen until many years
later
so we we didn't have the
characterization of the nature of the
specific units involved in the massacres
when did you enlist
uh
there's another story there
uh
i assumed that i would go into the army
uh
immediately when the war broke out and i
tried to get into different branches i
first applied for military intelligence
i knew french
and i thought that would be helpful i
knew other languages there was some
hungarian and yiddish
but my parents hadn't been citizens for
15 years and so i was disqualified and
then i tried to get into the air force
and uh first i was too short to be a
pilot and then i tried to be a navigator
then they changed the rules they could
they were they were altered a bit and
then i reapplied
and then i failed on one of my eyes
missed two letters on the 20 20 line
and then i tried to take training
exercises and while all this was going
on uh i was still in school
and
there's a very strange story that my
wife tells somebody watching over me to
make a long story short i tried to get
every branch of the service without
success until i got out of law school
i then went back to my draft board and i
i was very concerned that something had
happened
and the clerk of the draft board came
out to see me afterwards i told him i
have not been called up what's going on
here
and um
he had received a letter from the dean
um
and i think it was dean landis
in the middle of my first year
saying that it would take another month
or two before i'd finish the first year
and and they should give me a deferment
until the end of the year so i didn't
have a complete disruption
and they had granted that and i thought
then i would go in
but uh
the uh this member of the draft board
came up to me afterwards and he said how
did you do in law school
and i was very puzzled by that question
and uh he told me that he had been a
student at the yale law school in the
first world war
and he had been wounded and uh he had
never been able to go back to law school
and his life had been ruined
and
he just wanted to protect me from that
kind of uh experience
so it was just a a strange fluke i never
saw the man before i never saw him again
but
he reached his hand out
why did you want to go and why did you
want to enlist so badly when prior to
this you
well i felt uh i could have i could have
stayed out of the war in fact one of the
first doctors who examined me you know
you know i just about made the height
requirement and
i was having trouble with my stomach i
always had a nervous stomach and he said
well you won't qualify and i said why
not and he said well because we we can't
meet your dietary needs and so on but i
always felt that i didn't want to ask
anybody else to go and die for me
so i was trying to get in
where were you first assigned
where did you first go
uh well the army of course immediately
recognized my talent i was fresh out of
the harvard law school so they made me a
private in the artillery
and i was in the supply room uh as a
typist i couldn't type of course
and
as a matter of fact they really did
recognize my channel but in 30 days they
made me a private first class
so i figured out at that rate in 18
months i would be a general well of
course three years later i was still a
corporal
leave it to the army
i didn't like the army at all why
i hated the regimentation always
i felt the army all armies it was
nothing particularly directed against
the american or the german army for that
matter i think my hatred of the american
army may have equaled that of my for the
germans didn't know the germans but it's
the dehumanizing process that takes
place in an army
whereas part of the training the first
thing you do
is take human beings and make robots out
of them
and
i refused to become a robot and that
caused me endless grief in the army
because i was always
being reprimanded and sent on kp and
i refused to march
and i said that was the dumbest thing i
ever heard of i explained to my first
sergeant that the reason people marched
they went back to roman times when the
soldiers had to carry their shields on
the right side or the left side or over
their head
and march in formation because they were
being attacked by spears from the hills
and if they didn't move in formation the
spears could penetrate and kill them and
therefore was very important that they
moved as a unit
and i said that was very important i
said if we are going to attack any
romans with spears on a hill then that's
the way we should march but if we're
facing a guy with a machine gun and you
march in formation he'll kill you all so
what you have to do is not march in
formation you have to run dig a hole and
run in opposite directions okay wise guy
in the kitchen so off i went to the slop
pits and i cleaned more latrines and
more [ __ ] pits than anybody else in the
army which was very good training for
later life
didn't change you one bit
no it made my resentment greater i think
i hate all armies and i'm absolutely
anti-militaristic and i think the notion
of training a human being to push a
button which will result in killing a
million people or a hundred thousand
people and thinking nothing about it
is a horrendous thing to do and
incidentally that's exactly what the
germans did to the concentration camp
inmates the first thing they did was
dehumanize them shave off their hair
give them a number on their arm lose
their identity as people and that's how
you break the human spirit and it works
but it didn't work with me
how long did you stay in this
where were you assigned first well first
we went to basic training in carolina
which is great you know you march around
march all day march up and down again
and you do all those absolutely
ridiculous things that uh you do and i
kept on saying there's a war going on
don't you is there nothing more
important that i can do and just march
up and down here and you know clean out
the slop pits okay wise guy back again
into the kitchen you know so it was a
form of torture
i felt the united states army was
directing its torture at me personally
uh and it was a terrible time and uh i
had applied for officer candidate school
the
uh
major at that time or colonel uh on the
examining board had been my classmate at
harvard that sat next to me and he said
what are you doing here benny and i said
i'm applying for officer kennedy's well
of course of course
and uh
i had no problem passing it
but
that was never called and when we were
getting ready to go overseas my first
sergeant called me and he said you want
to be an officer here's your application
he threw it up in my face and threw it
in the trash can
and
my commanding officers felt the same way
i tried every means to get out of that
outfit i applied for the infantry for
the paratroopers for everybody and they
called me in and threatened to
court-martial me
for uh showing disrespect for the outfit
i was in and warned me that i would only
go out in a box
so
i was in the wrong outfit
what couldn't happen
well uh we went we were being trained
for the invasion of france
and uh we didn't know them but for
wherever the landing would take place
and uh
uh there was a 115th aaa gun battalion
of which i was a proud
private a corporal at the time i
eventually promoted me the couple
and
there was 116th
and
again
when you know
we weren't on the first wave but we were
supposed to go in very soon to shoot
down any of the uh high-flying aircraft
the barrage balloons were to take care
of the low-flying aircraft
and uh when the d-day came around and i
was
at the land's end in england waiting for
the invasion
uh
my outfit went over it was a couple of
days after d-day when they
had enough beach landed to
justify it and uh
my captain there was a new captain on
that job came and he said you stay here
and
again it was
one of those times when somebody reached
out
and and i was left
and uh
off they went
uh
and it was several days later was a week
or so later before i went across and
rejoined my outfit by that time the
germans had retreated from the beach
and
i was perched on top of a hill and
manning machine gun to make sure we
didn't get any attack from the rear
but from there on end it was just
chasing the germans all across germany
general patton was a commanding general
and
his tactic was to pursue and chase
sometimes i felt it was a rather
dangerous position that the germans had
counter-attacked we had no way of
repelling them but they didn't so off we
went
and
then of course i was
with that outfit all across france
and
luxembourg and
belgium and
and uh i found out when i was finally
discharged that i've been in five
campaigns and it was every campaign in
europe from the battle of the beaches of
normandy to the battle of the bulge
uh but
it wasn't necessary for me to be
shooting people through the head during
that time
so you didn't choose no
um
i mean the outfit was pursuing we were
fired upon i was under artillery fire
very frequently and tank fire and uh
but uh
we did shoot down a lot of planes
uh usually american planes
we didn't call it friendly fire then
which was a nice euphemism we invented
later
but uh the planes that were coming in
american planes
they had a gadget called identification
friend of foe which was supposed to give
off the signal telling us that they were
american planes and either they had
forgotten the signal or the equipment
was off or the
plane had been damaged in any case we
shot them down
and i had to go out
on several occasions and pick up pieces
of american flyers and hope that i could
find a fingerprint or a bit of a finger
to identify them
and the
fireworks of any aircraft fire may look
very nice on 4th of july but i don't go
to 4th of july celebrations
i don't like fireworks
uh i was uh
in an outfit which was commanded by uh
anti-semites um
most of the
or many of the people let me say in the
army were carry-overs from
the first world war people who couldn't
get a job in civilian life and a lot of
rednecks and
very frequently i was referred to as jew
boy
and when i was given some of the
dirtiest assignments
i was told you're a harvard man jew boy
do it again you know and they put me
through it again and again sweeping the
floor and it was never clean enough no
matter what and they just thought that
was great
and uh
they absolutely resented any effort of
mine to
to
get out of the outfit or
to become an officer or anything of that
kind so there was a lot of antagonism
between me and the military
was this typical
i think it was well i can't really talk
about typical of other outfits it was
very typical of this outfit yes for a
long time
not it didn't apply of course to all
officers but uh it certainly applied to
my first sergeant
who took out of the outfit when we got
to the shooting because i'm sure
somebody would have shot him
i'm not sure who it would have been
when did you get involved with the war
crimes teams
i was in
um
i think it was
before we reached luxembourg
uh because i recall
um
worked on adolf hitler strassa
uh in
alzet which is in luxembourg i was
called out of the outfit one day and
told you were being transferred out
which was a great shock and a surprise
to me because i tried to get out in the
worst way and i couldn't
and i'd been warned that you know i'd be
shipped out in a box and i'd send me
frontline infantry and make sure i got
killed and so on and then i arrived at
third army headquarters
in the judge advocate section i'd never
seen a judge advocate officer before
and i was told that i had been
recommended
for transfer from washington
and that uh
the unit had been instructed to set up a
war crimes branch in the u.s army
and the colonel who told me that said
your name has been given to us and uh
what's a war crime
and uh that was literally true he had no
idea what was meant by a war crime
it's a nice enough
kernel but
he had no such experience and i said sit
down colonel you're about to get an
education
and he sat down and i explained to him
because by that time i was quite an
authority on war crimes i had done all
the research
for a book by this harvard professor
look and i had read everything that had
been written about war crimes the first
world war and way back and
my job was to make summaries of
everything had been written all the
articles all the books
and i had a very retentive mind and i i
knew everything about war crimes i was
the only one who knew anything about it
so that's how that began
what was the next stage what what did
that mean once you were assigned
well they had five colonels and i was
the only enlisted man who were assigned
to that outfit the five colonels
uh were people who
were shell-shocked mostly tank officers
uh i don't recall at that time that any
of them were lawyers
they certainly had no idea whatsoever
about war crimes some of them i never
saw so but some were obviously
shell-shocked
um
and uh
i said you know the colonel look we need
help you know we've got to start we're
beginning to get reports of various
crimes against american flyers who had
been shut down
places that had been liberated mass
graves in different places
and
within a few days
the first
reinforcement arrived
and that was a
fellow wasn't much bigger than me and
uh by the name of jack nowitz
and he was a yale law graduate and he
was a buck private
uh from
an engineer battalion where he had been
busy building a bridge when they pulled
him out because of his knowledge of
languages and being a lawyer and he was
covered with mud
and uh he stood at attention and he
saluted me you know and he said he was
reporting for duty
and i said get off at soldier i'm just a
corporal
and that's how it began that was me
after a while we began to bring some
more people in but originally it was
just the two of us and with a few others
added a few enlisted men mostly
and then what did you do
well the typical
uh early investigation would be
uh we had a report for example of
american flyers parachutists who had
come down and been killed uh by the
populists down below
and uh
we had received such report from some
informer or somebody in the field and
had come through military intelligence
down to the war crimes unit and what i
would do then was i'd get into a jeep
and take off for the location
and very often by myself
or i'd have a jeep driver
and i'd arrive at the site
and
go to the nearest authority whether it's
the burgermeister or police chief or and
say we have a report of war crimes being
committed here and you know anything
about this of course i know nothing
about it sit down and write out an
affidavit and describe everything you
know
uh and if you lie you'll be shot
and i want you to arrest everybody
within the next you know the next 500
yards of this place and bring them in
here and sit down and have them write
statements
explain to them i'd find somebody who
spoke german at that time i didn't i'd
never studied german and i learned
german of course after a while but uh at
that time my german was very broken was
yiddish mostly but i managed to make
myself understood enough to get the job
done i would say
get somebody who knows english in german
and you'll you're the translator you
explain to these people and i arrest
maybe 50 or 75 people
um and say all of them sit down and
write out exactly what happened anybody
who lies will be shot
and they would stand at attention and
tremble and sit down and write and i
separately you know keep them all apart
then i collect the statements and say
now read them to me
and they would read them to me and
pretty soon if you read 75 statements
you get 40 of them telling you the same
thing the other saying i wasn't there i
never heard of anything i happened to be
milking the cow at that moment and so on
but with the 40 statements you knew what
had happened
so that i could write you know that on
this and this date
allied plane was shot down two american
fliers were captured
brought to the middle of the town there
they were beaten by the populace or they
were taken to the gestapo headquarters
and very there were many such cases and
uh then i would go to the gestapo
headquarters see if i could catch the
man they had invariably fled but i'd
capture the records and find out who was
in charge then i'd go try to find the
bodies
and dig them up uh sometimes i dug them
up myself sometimes i'd call the graves
registration and have them send in a
crew or something i'd stop the germans
and say start digging
and
i'd unearth the bodies call in camera
crew
signal core take pictures wash them down
try to identify them
and then write a report and issue an
arrest order
to all units to arrest so and so and so
and so at that time prisons of war were
being captured and being identified and
hold them for war crimes trials
so that kind of an investigation i could
do by myself
and i did
and
eventually people were caught eventually
i mean you know sometimes a matter of
weeks months
and uh we did set up war crimes trials
in the dachau concentration camp and i
hammered that sign up saying united
states army third army war crimes unit
dachau
and
that's where we began as act of poetic
justice the first war crimes trials long
before nuremberg
took place in the dahau concentration
camp
on the basis of evidence collected by me
and know it's and a few other guys like
us who went out into the field and uh
and collected the evidence
that's before we ran into the
concentration camps of course that was
a bigger operation how many trials did
you have there prior to the military i
don't know the the exact number because
i left um the trials were already on
while i was there but i left and they
were still going on when i came back
a long time later a year or so later
was prosecuting at nuremberg those
trials were still going on to give you
some idea of the flavor of those trials
which i thought were terrible i thought
they were terrible
they brought very little resemblance to
a normal due process of law and i must
confess that i was partly uh guilty and
responsible
for
that kind of behavior i mean i if i had
a a
an ss man in my custody and he insisted
upon lying that he wasn't even there
when i had 20 witnesses saying he was
there
um
he usually
ended up with a confession
um it was not that i had to shoot him
through the head in order to get it
but
he certainly was of the impression that
if he continued lying i would
and
under those circumstances
i would always bring in an officer and
tell him to go and get that confession
again
because the one the original one would
probably not stand up to close scrutiny
but
the trials themselves at the hour were
the judges were officers with no legal
training usually
they had no better assignment the
procedures were very informal i'm not
suggesting that we tried their
punished innocent people on the contrary
they're all guilty as hell
otherwise we wouldn't have tried in the
first place we had too many guilty ones
let let loose but
so i was not
very impressed
with the quality of the law work being
done at daha on the contrary some of my
letters that i wrote home i said this is
a disgrace that uh you know we've
forgotten our ideals and all that so it
was a
difficult time and uh most of my
more interesting times really were in
apprehending the
some of these
relatively minor criminals or in
collecting the evidence of these smaller
crimes there were also some massacres of
civilians in different towns mass graves
things of that kind but nothing near
like the concentration camps themselves
before we get on to that were you
frightened when you went out to
investigate no you weren't no i was mad
i don't recall ever having any sense of
fear
there was some sense of outrage it was
not a sense of
vengeance that was not one of my
emotions
but i was quite determined
and
it was a job that you know i realized
had to be done
and i was so engrossed in getting the
job done
uh that there was no time for fear nor
was there any any real fear i mean i uh
uh i i don't know that emotion
did you actually have authority to go
into a place and say i'm arresting you
75 or was this something you made up on
the spot so you could get what you
wanted well according to my rank i had
no authority whatsoever and i was aware
of that
but i had more authority than anybody
else because nobody else knew or cared
what i was doing
and in order to give myself that
authority i had written out a an
authorization
request from the commanding general who
was patent
saying that all units are requested to
give all assistance to t5 that's
technician fifth grade otherwise known
as corporal friends who is conducting
war crimes investigations on behalf of
this headquarters and
all assistance you know should be given
to him and using that i could go into a
colonel and say look here i'm here in a
war crimes investigation and i want you
to send me a company of troops to
surround this area or to hold this
area you know closed or seal it or
whatever whatever it was that i needed
to do
now sometimes the colonel would say oh
no you know i said listen you want me to
call up patton directly uh if you do i
will and he'll straighten you out and i
had no respect whatsoever for military
authority i had nothing but contempt the
higher the rank the more contempt
and it invariably worked very well so
that i had no difficulty in uh
because i want no insignia of any kind
and i refuse to wear insignia when my
lieutenant colonel was promoted to full
colonel in recognition of his splendid
word for war crimes he called me in with
great pride he said you know he said i
realize this is done you know as a
result of your efforts and i show you my
appreciation i want to give you these
stripes and he made me a sergeant
so i took the stripes and i threw him
right in his trash can and i said i'm
sorry sir but these stripes only
interfere with my work i cannot go
around as a sergeant and do what i'm
doing because i cannot command the
authority that i need to do the job so
you'll excuse me if i don't wear them
and he was of course very insulted by
that and i think the final act
that
he did before he was transferred out
before i think colonel bill denson came
in was he left instructions to have me
reduced to private
you were a colonel i was then a and that
was my chrono he was going to make me a
sergeant with three stripes but i
couldn't do my job as a sergeant either
and
so i refused to wear the stripes and uh
all of my war pictures you'll never find
any insignia on me
no this was this uh
your real reason for not wanting the
stripes because in fact you couldn't do
your job oh yes absolutely absolutely i
uh
it goes back to your first question what
authority did i have
a private a corporal sergeant has no
authority in the army to do any of this
but the job had to be done and so i got
the job done and i didn't pay attention
to uh the absence of military rank by
which i cared not one bit
you know
they wanted to promote me to sergeant
long before and i refused that somebody
else was a buddy of mine who's been
waiting long i should give it to him i
don't want
when you left
those dachau trials that's before the
the military tribunal came in for the
dachau camp trials yes what was
where did then did you go you went to
the concentration camps and well
i've described to you the earliest war
crimes investigations which were
killing of hostages
in france in belgium malmedy massacre
for example a better known one shooting
down of allied flies
and then we ran into buchenwald first
um
i had never heard the name buchenwald
that was something just as i had never
heard the word einstein's baby
which i was much involved with later we
didn't know those names we knew there
was a concentration camp a report would
come in the third army headquarters that
so-and-so tank division is approaching
an area in which they believe there is a
concentration camp or has just overrun
an area in which there is a
concentration camp and the conditions
are horrible
etc and
that would come to me the report would
come to me and i'd say i'm going out
into the field to investigate that
later on we had others who would go out
into the field but i was very eager
to
go out and because i was the most
experienced man in the outfit and nobody
else knew what to do in fact i would go
out
and going out meant i'd
get there as fast as i possibly could
usually on a jeep
find out which unit was going in or had
just entered and go into the camp
and
what i would do immediately
would be to secure the records
there was in every camp a shrimp strip
or an office
uh i'd go into the shrimp sugar
immediately but shlagnam describes to
which means you'd see so i'd seize the
shrive shoe and everything in it nobody
could and nobody out all records are
confiscated and secured
for example in broken wild i seized the
totem bushes the death books which were
the registries of the people killed in
buchenwald uh they were long big black
books uh
bound they were not the loosely folders
but there they recorded the name of all
the inmates as they were killed
and they would put down next to them the
date the name the date of birth usually
if they had it of the
of the inmate and his number of course
and uh
uh then the reason for his death and
they were also obviously fictitious of
their floch
shot while trying to escape ortifos
typhoid or or other diseases and those
books then became
the uh the basic evidence
for uh what had happened in the camp and
who was there
and uh
then i would follow that up by bringing
in
witnesses from the survivors to take
statements from them describing what had
happened in the camp and by the time i
got through and usually took two or
three days not usually more i had a
complete picture and on the basis of
that i could go back to headquarters
write a report an issue arrest warrants
for everybody connected with it
ben let's talk again about buchenwald
you said that there was a prisoner there
who had been burying some material that
you wanted to talk about
uh i'm not sure it was broken wild in
fact
[Music]
i should perhaps mention that
i was moving very quickly from one camp
to the next as soon as i secured the
evidence in the camp and i heard there
was another camp someplace else i raced
off to the other camp because if he
didn't do that everything was destroyed
the american army for one would come in
and destroy everything they could and
the inmates themselves tore everything
apart
so i was moving from one camp to another
buchenwald i didn't remember the name
buchenwald at the time i remember audrav
because we took pictures at urdraft and
these additional slave labor camps all
around the main camps there were many of
them
so i would go from one camp to the next
haven say mud house in flossenberg
ordruff these are names that i recall
and that come to mind sometimes i knew
it at the time and usually i didn't i
just knew it was a concentration camp
and in one of those camps it may have
been broken wild
but i don't think so it was probably
havency or flossenberg
and it wasn't mount housing that was too
big
one of the
inmates in the shrivestuba
came to me as soon as i came in and he
said i've been waiting for you
and i said what for and he said come
with me
and he took a shovel and he took me out
of the room which was their office
and
we walked away into the camp next to the
electric fence which was part of the
surrounding barbed wire
and there he dug a hole and i remember
it was right near the post of a fence
and he dug a hole with the shovel and
then he took out a bundle it was a box
wrapped in
looked like rags
and he said let's go back to the office
and went back to the office and he
opened this
well apparently in that particular camp
the ss had their own sort of social club
where they went for drinking at night
and membership in the club was evidenced
by a little identity card two sides
folded together inside with their
photograph and check off how many times
they attended the club and had the name
of the man and the date of birth and
other identifying things as well as the
membership and when the
stamps were filled on that club on that
card he got another card and this inmate
had to type up the new one and destroy
the old ones
instead of destroying the old ones he
saved them
every time he did that he ran the risk
of being killed
for disobeying orders but he saved them
and he put them all together and he
buried them
knowing that one day there would be a
day of retribution and for him to have
risked his life every day
and yet retained the hope that there
would be freedom for him someday i
thought was a marvelous thing and it was
tremendous piece of evidence because i
had the record and the photograph and
identification of every ss man who had
gone through that camp in that period of
time
what was it like for you to go into
these camps
what did you see
well i'm sure that uh everybody by this
time has seen
the photographs of what the camp looked
like
and bodies
lying in the dust
naked
a
little item of clothing on
many of them not moving some of them
stirring
mostly bones
human being you know
men weighing 50 60 pounds
the medical troops came in at the same
time
people were being hosed down with the
hose held up with one hand and i've done
that too hose them with with a hose held
in one hand and hold up a man in the
other hand who weighs about 40 or 50
pounds and is nothing but bones
and then of course the piles of bodies
in front of the crematoria stacked up
like cord wood and on the on the
the carts that were dragging them to the
crematory these open carts just loaded
with bodies hands and arms hanging out
on all sides
i remember all of that very vividly of
course
but what
struck me i think is
uh
most appalling of all
uh were the
human beings who had been so dehumanized
that in their appearance they looked
like rodents they would go on all fours
hands turned to claws looking for some
potato peel scurrying in the garbage
piles just like rats you know grabbing
trying to find some bit of food stuffing
it into their mouths quickly and looking
around you know furtively is you know
just as you would expect any animal
and
these were human beings who had been
dehumanized by this terrible process
to which they had been subjected
and i always marveled in later years
when i'd meet people
whom i didn't recognize of course but i
knew they'd been through that and they
seemed to be quite normal
i knew that they couldn't be quite
normal
but
[Music]
if you touch some spark you know some
spot the crack
shows
but this whole
process so what happened to human beings
struck me as
more terrible than people who were on
the verge of death who were dying
out of starvation of disease and so on
uh in other camps like
mud house and i remember mount housing
very vividly because it was a very big
camp and i got in very early
and uh
it was a terrible it was you know
finished lager really where they were
killing people by throwing them off the
cliff into the quarry down below
guzen one and guzen ii
and of course the mass graves everywhere
and
i i uh there was typhus in the camp and
i couldn't spend the night there to get
out of the camp as fast as i could i did
my working on then got out i wouldn't
spend the night there and dysentery
people lying around in their own filth
and excrement you know one on top of the
other in the bunks you know uh one on
top of the other three four five in a
bunk maybe somebody above and
everybody's sick you know throwing up
blowing at both ends you know and the
stench and the and the disease and the
despair and somebody holding up my hand
you know for a glass of water or drink
or something like that so it's really
you know quite unimaginable to uh to a
normal mind
and that people could subject other
people to that kind of treatment
is something i will never recover from
go on with your questions
oh
did you have to leave when you would go
into a camp for a little while and just
get out not not to get away from the
scene
uh the work was so overwhelming
that i never faulted in in the job i
never felt that i had to stop because i
couldn't carry on i carried on very well
and it was though i just built a wall
to uh to cut it out you know and and
just to go ahead and do what had to be
done and don't let it impact
on your emotional response to it
so
i left the camps because the conditions
were such that it was dangerous to stay
but only after i had done what i had to
do
were these prisoners
uh ever in any condition so they could
be talked to i mean did you take names
oh yes oh yes there were many of them
who were
and in fact that's where i used those
are the ones from whom i collected
statements immediately you know some of
them were in fairly good shape and uh
they were in such good shape that they
went chasing after the ss uh i described
in one of my letters as a scene of an ss
man trying to escape being murdered by
the prisoners who were chasing him
and he wanted me to take him prisoner
and
he had
a civilian jacket on he'd put the
civilian jacket on and attempt to escape
and he just jumped on the jeep and he
said please you know take me prison i
don't remember if he was speaking german
or english anymore probably german
and uh i said show me your papers and he
showed me his papers and i could see he
was an ss man
and i said it's not your papers it were
not his there was some other papers that
he picked up somewhere
and i said i don't take civilian
prisoners and pushed him off and at that
uh at that point these two uh looked
like russians inmates came across the
hill on a bicycle and they had rifles
trapped over their back and they just
took their
rifle out and he saw them come in he ran
in front of my jeep
uh there were troops moving up to the
front
trucks and so on and
just as he ran in front of the jeep one
of the men
the inmates shot him in the back
and he
fell
in front of this truck which hit him and
sent him flying on the side of the road
and the truck driver jumped out you know
and a gi and he he said i don't know
what happened he jumped in front of the
truck and i just said keep on moving so
you get on you know and roll them into
the ditch
so there was an upsurge of the inmates
themselves on a rampage
as soon as those gates were opened they
went on a rampage and any german who was
within reach
rude the day you know they stripped
their homes they raped their women they
burned the houses down you know
um so
there were many who were quite capable
of still you know working and thinking
and talking and those who seem to be you
know knowledgeable
and better educated uh i try to catch
them immediately and have them give me a
statement what had happened where they
came from describe who was in the camp
what the circumstances were describing
some of the torture mechanism which
existed in some of these camps chains
and walls against which they shot people
and people had thrown on the wires and
all that so uh there was an uh an ample
field for a credible reliable testimony
from the inmates themselves and i
collected those wherever i could
was was this revenge
rather common because
peop some people have said there was
very little revenge or no revenge of
jews didn't go out well it depends on
how weak they were a person who
could hardly lift their head had no
feeling of revenge
these two
i think there were soviet pows in the
camp
[Music]
they were not that weak they wanted to
kill as many germans as they could get a
hold of and they did
uh and i've seen them beating inmates to
death
burning them alive uh you know it was a
very gory business
you mean not beating inmates but no
beating guards they caught the guards
they caught the camp commandant uh and
beat him up not to kill him but because
they wanted to burn him alive and they
did and
i suppose as a soldier i might have
tried to stop them
but i was usually alone and you know the
troops the tanks had come and gone
passed on ahead and uh those who had
been able to flee the ss officers they
fled as fast as they could but the guys
who got caught there
um
you know they were they were seized by
the inmates and taking care of quick
trial
or some of the russians said to me i
read met the russians outside of weimar
we came into buffalo one side the
russians were coming in from the others
there and i met to the russian troops
and
we were sort of fraternizing difficulty
of communication but there were some
with whom we could communicate and one
of them said to me he said what's the
matter with your americans what are you
crazy you know what they did why do you
ask them what they did no he said you
are crazy kill him kill him
and uh
they did and they did
uh we had a different approach to it at
the time i'm not sure which one was
right in the long run but that was you
know whether americans were over there
when american soldiers ever shot ss
when the americans ever shot i never saw
that now
um
no
i mean
except perhaps in combat i mean if they
were fired at when entering a camp i'm
sure they fired back and i'm sure that
there were casualties in any such
exchange but just taking out ss men and
saying for revenge i'm going to kill you
now
uh
i
i never saw such a an execution nor have
i do i recall ever having heard of such
an execution were there women prisoners
oh yes were these calves oh yes
there were many women and they were
little children which surprised me too
and they were young boys the boys were
usually abused by the ss gods
homosexuals and others in exchange for
favors in the camp and there were little
children who were born in the camps and
were somehow concealed by the mothers
and in different places
and uh you know in these slave labor
camps surrounding the whole network
right outside the main camp uh different
distances whatever they were able to do
by way of work and sometimes the very
small children were put to work and
doing things curling wires and doing
things where little had was better than
a big one
so and it was quite remarkable that they
survived there were gypsies as well who
survived and they were also marked for
total extermination but very soon you'd
see a gypsy with a wagon and a horse
which of course he had requisitioned
somewhere
liberated as they called it
so did you go into many camps and
sub-camps during this period
i moved from one camp to the next as
fast as i could it was important to get
into the camps as quickly as possible
otherwise the evidence was destroyed
the troops have a way of celebrating
liberation of any place by smashing
everything in sight
and
that may be very good
to relieve the tension but it's not very
good for collecting war crimes evidence
so by the time i got up to the eagles
nest embarrasses garden
the main window looking out in this
beautiful view looking down on the alps
and so on there wasn't a splinter of
glass left that was gone
and every file cabinet and every bathtub
had been filled by a gi leaving his best
regards to mr hitler and the same thing
appeared elsewhere so there was nothing
there which was no longer usable
not that there has been very much there
in the first place it was all in berlin
which had been
in the bunker and elsewhere but it was
very important to preserve the evidence
to move in quickly and this is a problem
which i'm sure war crimes investigators
are having today
so what then happened you were gathering
all of this evidence and by the way
where is jack know it's all this time
and jack knows he's doing the same thing
someplace else uh and we'd get home
together and meet at the office say
where have you been and he said well
i've been down so and so where have you
been i've been so and so occasionally
we'd go out together uh on a job you
know of some kind and you cover this and
i'll cover that
and then we'd come back to our office
so-called the office was the third army
judge advocate headquarters which kept
moving as the front kept moving up it
was either near longan or it was in
munich or it was uh someplace else and
you know we had usually took over german
concern we had a room and a desk and a
typewriter so i would get back there
with whatever notes i had whatever
documents i had and write up a report
and
the reports would say on a certain date
u.s army troops entered the camp of x
let's assume mud housing for example
there the troops encountered the
following scene there were originally
fifty thousand inmates in the camp there
were twelve thousand still alive ten
thousand had been marched out the days
before the camp offices were so and so
the crematorial was still going there
were so many bodies stacked in front of
the crematoria i took witness statements
from ten witnesses
their attaches exhibits one to ten um
the suspected persons responsible for
these crimes are so and so and so and so
issue orders immediately to have them
put on the crowcast list the central
registry of war criminals and security
suspects uh have them distributed to all
members of the us army wherever any pows
are care compare them with this list
have them arrested and report back to
headquarters so the goal of my
investigation was to describe what had
happened to collect credible evidence
admissible in a court of law
which could be used to convict the
persons responsible of a known
crime under international law that was
the objective and that's what we did um
and there were very few of us doing that
noah's was one i was one and later we
got a few more people in but the total
number was never more than half a dozen
or a dozen
who were competent
to know what represented a war crime and
to prepare a report which would stand up
in a court of law that then became the
basic materials for the prosecution to
come in and say to the defendant
your name was listed and so and so
so-and-so said so and so what do you
have to say
uh
and and that's the way it went so you
you folks are the war crimes teams we're
the war crimes team we're the war crimes
team there are a few officers around his
decoration
because only officers could take us one
statement so when you had this one
statement you sent him to the officer
and you said you signed there and he
said what's that for you said that's an
affidavit that's an affidavit what's an
affidavit that's an affidavit just one
statement you sign right here yes sir
okay lieutenant so-and-so or captain
so-and-so and that was it
and that was the evidence of war crimes
isn't that funny
one thing that comes to mind which
struck me particularly at the time was
the may first the may day celebration in
one of the concentration camps i think
it was even say
where the inmates were celebrating their
liberation and the may day it was
organized by the communists who were in
charge of most of the camps immediately
after liberation they were best
organized there was a big tribune with
roosevelt and stalin and churchill and
there were going to be big speeches but
first there was going to be a parade of
the inmates and they were broken down
national groups the
russians marched the red banner and the
french and the italians and the
yugoslavs and the romanians and i don't
know hungarians and then there was a
group marching along a bedraggled group
and they had no flag and i asked one of
the inmates who are they and they said
oh those are the jews i said why don't
they march with you said no no the jews
they're separate that's not us the other
jews
so there was the anti-semitism
still in the camp after liberation
as a reflection you know of the ethnic
hostility which we see today in many
parts of the world still
and
another
event which
strikes me as
perhaps noteworthy is that
as the camps were about to be liberated
the germans tried to
move the inmates out those who are still
able to walk or to work they left those
behind to be killed to die who was too
sick but they marched them out and they
were marching
i think it was from flossenburg to march
to daho or one of the camps
and they took them through the woods and
they marched at night
and if anybody faulted on the way they
were immediately shot if anybody paused
to try to pick up a potato or to eat a
root or something
they were shot
and i was able to follow this trail
through the woods
uh of mass graves
10 20 30 50 killed you know and i would
get the nearest farmer to say dig them
up they would say oh yes we heard firing
there last night there was shooting
going on where was it over there in the
woods
and uh i would say let's go and we'd go
out to the woods and there would be a
newly dug up place and i'd say get some
shovels and i'd stop some germans on the
street take the shovels dig them up and
we dig up the bodies of people who have
been obviously shot through the head
usually the top of the skull was blown
off uh shot probably kneeling from the
back
some of them were tied still
you know just lightly covered over with
uh
you know
six inches of dirt something like that
they could follow the trail of crime
being committed all along the way
and uh
there was nothing you could do i mean we
were trying to overtake the column which
was by that time it already been
liberated up ahead uh in some place and
some other unit had taken over
and
one of the difficulties i remember was
the
as an american soldier to resist the
temptation to try to feed
some of these people we all carried
emergency rations of chocolate bars
which were like a brick you know we
carried it in our gun belt in case you
really got into a jail you could hit it
without bayonet and break out for peace
you know and survive that way but if we
gave it to an inmate we were able to
kill him and it happened a lot of the
gi's were giving away whatever they had
i once had a can of sod a case of
sardines i liberated somewhere and gave
it out to the inmates and that was my
first reminder i mustn't do that because
it would kill them if they ate a can of
sardines they would kill them
we had to begin by feeding them soup for
a week
and begin with a very light soup until
their stomachs and systems were built up
so you know
it's hard for me to where do i draw the
line i remember in the avensay
concentration camp
uh i'm quite sure it was even say too
there were mass bodies everywhere and we
had to bury them right away because of
the disease
and we buried them
outside the camp and
slit trenches we had trenches and we
just you know you've seen people with
bulldozers i don't think we use
bulldozer had the germans pick them up
and just carry them and throw them into
this ditch
a few years later i came back with
one of my employees dr katzenstein who
became a key man and one of the
organizations set up to help nazi
victims and his wife
didn't know why we were in german i said
i'll show you why
and i took them on a tour of some of
these camps and we got to have and say
and there they were all neatly marked
graves with crosses on them you know
and i said that's a lot of baloney
because i know i was here when they were
being buried i have pictures of me
walking past you know this so-called
cemetery well they found names of
inmates who died in the camp and just
put a marker on which i suppose is all
they could do
but
it was a nightmarish world you know
something very
surrealistic
about it and and bears very little
reality you know to what a normal human
being would understand even
do you consider the so the liberation of
the camps really liberation or did was
this accidental coming upon
what you were doing no no it was real
liberation uh that was not the primary
goal the troops were moving forward and
they stumbled upon many of these camps
they didn't know they were there in some
cases the intelligence had reports and i
had a map a war map showing camps at
different sites uh of the major camps so
we knew they were there and we would
move for them and i could tell that we
were probably gonna hit that camp in
three or four or five days and get ready
for it but what we didn't know was all
these sub camps that were scattered all
around there were hundreds of them
everywhere there were hundreds of them i
have a list here of over a thousand
concentration camps run by the germans
and german industry and the germans
themselves didn't know we added another
three or four hundred later i don't know
how many thousands we have right now so
these so-called small camps which may
have had a couple of hundred people in
them uh they existed everywhere and they
were so similar people were dying they
were killed they were lying around you
couldn't tell that from the living
did you in terms of the feeding of the
prisoners were you told to not feed the
prisoners or did you just learn this we
learned it we learned it i mean there
was no time you know to
sit down and have big briefings uh it
was a very very mobile and hectic
atmosphere of uh you know tension and
movement and
drama but you soon learned that if you
gave somebody some food and you saw him
choke on it and drop dead you know but
uh he you didn't do that again
so it was not i don't recall anybody
giving me a lecture about that but was
pretty well known that the the the camps
the medicals the medical men that came
in they began with you know intravenous
feeding and with this water and and tea
and you know a little soup and that was
it
so we saw you know what was going on
how would you describe your mental state
going through these camps
you were blocking yourself to feeling
anything
it was very interesting as i look back
upon it
i think the human body has a capacity
for survival
which enables it to build up insulation
insulating mechanisms
to prevent yourself from going mad
and
i do not recall
feelings of
rage i do not recall feelings of fear
i do not recall feelings of hatred
uh i do recall
the urgency of doing something and
getting the job done before it's too
late so i went about my business
as best i could and i did it i think
very well
by putting myself into a mental cocoon
which was surrounded by
an ice barrier
which just enabled me to go on
and uh
that ice barrier lasted until it melted
you know but as long as it was necessary
to do the job it remained there as a
self-protective device i think
okay now you're
you've gathered all of this material
and the war crimes teams have a lot of
this evidence now now what's going to
happen yes
now
the higher headquarters have got to
decide what to do about war crimes
trials
the president has declared
we're going to have war crimes trials
hitler and his henchmen have been put on
notice that they would be held
accountable for the concentration camps
of whatever else they did
the governments had to act
they were not yet ready to act the war
had just ended
the army already had these records we
were already we had the prisoners we had
to do something with them
and in third army there was a 12th army
corps group headquarters in wiesbaden i
think they wanted me to come and work
with them that's how i remember that i
got a letter from the general asked me
if i wanted to be transferred to his
headquarters and uh may have been
colonel denson who dealt with that and
uh i said listen i don't want to do his
work anymore that i want to do yours i
want to get out of the army that's all i
want to go home
but i recall having nailed up the sign
headquarters third united states army
war crimes trials da hao
we decided that we were going to have
the trials in daha nada was liberated by
the seventh army not the third army but
we were occupying general patton was
there and that was the situs where we
were going to have trials and so we took
these
army officers who had been assigned to
the judge advocate section not because
they were lawyers but because
they were at liberty and we needed staff
and they had nobody else and
they were going to set up tribunals
these were in fact military tribunals uh
they're not to be confused with uh what
happened later at the international
military tribunal at nuremberg which was
an international court these were
military-style tribunals which have
existed under the laws of war for a very
long time
and they were staffed by
military officers similar to a court
martial it followed the court-martial
procedure so they would have three
officers a colonel a major or captain or
whatever the highest ranking was the
presiding officer the prosecutors were
selected by the judge advocate group
they may or may not have been lawyers
sometimes they were sometimes they
weren't they were lieutenants assigned
to defend so-and-so or to prosecute
so-and-so as they would a soldier who'd
gone a wall
and then they had all these nice reports
prepared by me by knoweth by a few other
guys [ __ ] nick was another lawyer who
came on board and we had a fellow named
briggs who was a lawyer went up to
boston well these were enlisted men and
they did all the work
and they'd have these reports and based
on those reports they would we would
drop the indictment i would drop the
indictment uh and the indictment would
say that
uh
ss
major so-and-so is indicted for mass
murder of so many concentration camp
inmates and such and such camp during
such and such period when he was in
command
and the evidence is photographs obtained
by the signal core statements from the
survivors my own affidavit or other
affidavits of witnesses who were there
usually not my own i would certify to
the procedures whereby these affidavits
were obtained
and um
on the basis of that the defendant would
be asked how do you plead
and they say i plead not guilty all
right let's proceed with the trial
and they proceeded with the trial and
some of these were quite interesting for
example if we're telling stories
i arrested
a woman in the town of gross gerard
which is near frankfurt
it was a typical allied flyer case
typical allied player is that any allied
fire coming down on the orders from
hitler was to be killed as a war
criminal he was to be taken into custody
and killed that was the orders from
berlin
and so this allied flyer came down
in this town
and the townspeople immediately set upon
him and began to beat him up
and eventually he was taken by i think
it was a fireman or an ss man and they
split his head with a crowbar
and killed him
but uh
and i knew who that was and i got a hold
of him too but uh
anyway there's one of these women who
was beating this flyer on the head with
a shoe
and i think it was her mother
who testified against her she said i
told my daughter not to do that
and uh
i said what's your daughter's name name
is so-and-so where is your daughter now
and he thought it was so-and-so and i
got a hold of the daughter and i said
you were beating those flies with the
shoe who me not me
don't tell me not you lady because i
know it was you it was your red shoe you
got a red shoe you beat him on the head
with a red shoe with the heel of the red
shoe
yeah well that's true but but you know
he had just been bombed my town i lost
my children my husband was killed she
gave me a big sob story of some of which
may have been true
and she was quite an attractive woman
too and a young woman
and i thought well look i got the guy
who split his head and the whole mob was
beating him up and
uh
i put her under house arrest i didn't
want to bother you know tearing up
when that trial came up at daho
uh i happened to be there
and one of the uh guys you know says
well we you you handled the gross gear
out case didn't i said yes well we got
the trial on oh i'll call them take a
look so i go and sure enough i spot this
lady there and i
spot the guy who did the job
uh
and
at a certain point in the trial his
trial didn't last long less than a day
or two
and that was it
uh and uh
this woman fainted in the dark
and the doctor went up and i i said to
the doctor i know that woman i said
what's what's wrong with that he said
nothing to worry about he said she's
just pregnant i'm an american soldier
one of the prison guards
now there's a story
was she trying to avoid a death penalty
by getting herself impregnated was she
in love with the german with the
american gi was the gi attached to her
i think she got about 18 months prison
sentence or something like that the guy
who split his head was sentenced to
death
i don't know whether he was ever
executed or not
maybe he was they did execute some
but not all
and those trials came to an end while we
were at nuremberg because i kept an eye
on them sort of
and
i think there was a colonel tomlinson i
think it went down from nuremberg to be
one of the colonels on those trials
and they got orders from the pentagon
were ending war crimes trials and so the
presiding judge said the war crimes
trials are off everybody got home
and the trials were over and the
criminals got up and walked out of the
dock
and that was the end of that
so
uh that's how you deal with war crimes
so there were thousands of
indictments and few
well we didn't draw thousands of
indictments there were certainly many
thousands of criminals
that there were there were very few
indictments and fewer trials and fewer
which had any significance
and
these were
based on military pattern
of military trials against american
soldiers for violating the rules of
the military code in one way or another
that was the closest analogy to it they
had no significance in international law
they had no political significance
really
we had hoped some of us were involved in
the early days had hoped that it would
be more than that but by the time i left
the army which was uh you know before i
went back for nuremberg it was quite
obvious to me that these trials were uh
or not to be
given any historical significance at all
had best be forgotten but they are an
early record of what happened uh in the
camps which were liberated by the
americans our goal there was to try only
those
uh commanding officers in the camps
which had been liberated by the american
army or those who had committed crimes
against american soldiers and this where
we got into all these uh
allied flyer cases and things of that
kind
do you think it was a mistake to have
these trials based on the
military law and court martial no it
wasn't a mistake because anytime you
bring anybody to justice even if it's an
inadequate court it's better than not
bringing him to justice at all and we
could have followed the russian pattern
and just shot them um
i never really favored that i may have
felt that way but i never really favored
that as a principal as a lawyer it
seemed to me that it's not something we
ought to do
you may be interested to know the
british favored that and
the russians certainly not only favored
it they did it
and it was quick justice
sometimes just sometimes unjust i'm sure
they
killed people who were undeserving
but
if you adopt the theory that any
person who sails on a pirate ship must
expect to hang from the yadam
there was a form of rough justice and
i'm not sure that the detailed justice
in the so-called military commissions or
courts whatever we called them at the
time was any better in the long run
than uh
allowing a rampage as the russians did
cutting it off
i got out of the army great day of my
life i was so eager to get away from
germany i never wanted to hear the name
german again or germany again or camps
again or army of any kind again and home
i went
and uh i was home for a few weeks
and i got a
telegram
asking me to come to washington
dear sir
please at our expense would you kindly
come to washington we would like to talk
to you signed by colonel mickey marcus
mickey marcus later became
quite renowned
as a
jewish general a west pointer who went
to fight in the israeli army and
unfortunately he was killed there
but he was recruiting
for the war crimes trials which were
then being set up at nuremberg
and
he had somehow gotten wind of what i had
been doing at dachau
and i was one of the few people who was
qualified by legal training to
understand war crimes and by experience
in the field as an active war crimes
investigator were also involved in
setting up the trials
so his job colonel marcus's job was to
recruit staff
for
uh originally he wanted me to go back to
the dachau trials
but
he was working out of the pentagon
and i went to see him and uh i had never
met him before and he said benny we want
you to go back to germany
i said sir you want me to go back to
germany he said yes we need guys like
you you understand those bastards and
you know you're gonna go back there and
you know where you we need you
i said in order to get me into the army
and to go back to germany you have to
declare war on germany again and be
losing
i said otherwise i don't go back into
the army know how
and uh so
he said look
you can't do this we need you now
desperately all these years they didn't
need me at all
and um he said you know the field and
you know you've got the right attitude
and you've got the right experience and
so on and he said you name your terms he
said in any terms you want
i said well i won't go back into the
army no matter what i don't trust the
army i've seen them double crossing
lying people you're on the military
committee said no he said i'll let you
go as a civilian and i'll give you a
military rank i said what rank he said
i'll make you a colonel
aha
i said for three years the colonels had
been sticking it to me you know in the
army said this is my chance
i said i'll let you know so i went out
and i telephoned to the young lady
gertrude
who had been waiting patiently for 10
years
and i said how would you like to go to
europe for a honeymoon
and she said oh this is so sudden
and i explained the situation she said
it would be great i said i'm going to
take the job for six months and we're
going to go back and we're going to have
a honeymoon and i'm just going to stick
it to all these lieutenant colonels
who've been sticking it to me for all
these years
so i go back to marcus and i say i'll
take the job for six months as a
civilian with the rank of a full colonel
he said you got a deal okay drop the
papers
then i got intercepted
by a call from
also then a colonel telfer taylor
and
would i come and talk to him
and he said look i'm going back to
nuremberg i've been over there the
international military tribunal is
already in process justice jackson is
there we're winding up that trial but
i'm going to take over after him and
we're going to set up a whole series of
subsequent trials
and i'm going to be in charge and i need
staff and i've heard about you
and i'd like you to come with me and i
say what have you heard about me and he
said i heard that you're occasionally
insubordinate and i said that's not
correct i'm usually insubordinate
because i will not follow orders that i
know are stupid
i said but i've also been checking up on
you
and i know you're a harvard man i know
your background and i don't think you're
going to give me stupid orders and if
you don't you couldn't get a better man
he said you come with me so i said fine
i called up marcus i said marcus i'm off
that army junket i'm going out with
telford taylor
and
so i did
still intending to have nothing but a
good time and
enjoy myself and get even with the u.s
army
well it turned out that telford was an
excellent lawyer
uh and he was much engrossed in the
whole problem of who do you try after
you've tried these few leading germans
when you have the entire hierarchy of
german life also responsible the
ministries the industrialists the
generals the ss people
the doctors the lawyers
all of them conspired together to make
it possible for hitler to do what he was
doing and telford's approach was
we have to reach out
into all these segments of german
society in order to demonstrate how it
really worked
and it was quite fascinating and i
really took the work quite seriously
and i said all right
he said what do you want me to do he
said where do i begin where do i go i
said we got to get the evidence
he said i'll go to berlin that's where
all the evidence is
so he said you go to berlin set up an
office in berlin
so i went to berlin
my wife i had to leave behind
and
there i set up the office of the chief
of council for war crimes berlin branch
and to show you how things worked and
how my army training stood me in good
stead
uh the first office to which they
assigned me was in the cellar of the
building known as harnack house a famous
house in berlin and on the floor i found
a picture of president truman who was
lying in the dirt
no frame
so i got
somebody i said get me a picture frame
so i got the picture frame
and
i put the picture in and i wrote on it
to my friend benny from harry
i put it on the wall
now you know i have a friend by the name
of harry friedman he could have given me
that picture
then i called up the commanding colonel
of berlin i said i'd like to talk to you
colonel how soon can you get over here
to my office
sorry
so who's this calling i said this is
mr ferenz
uh
i'm here on assignment from the
president united states
to carry out a war crimes mission on
behalf of the united states government
and my office is in hanakos i want you
to come over right away
yes sir okay you came over i said you
don't expect me to carry on this job in
this office look at this we have five or
six rotten rooms here i said a seller we
need proper quarters
how are we going to get our jobs done he
looks at this picture of truman on the
wall
and says yes sir yes sir and immediately
i got a whole building a half of the
building right next to general clay's
headquarters and of course then we
brought in staff and we had a staff of
about 50 people
and what we did we scoured all the
german archives most of the staff were
german speaking former refugees many of
them jewish
who had fled hitler who knew the german
scene and we had the german foreign
office archives we had
eight or nine million nazi party records
in a bunker under a little chateau
in the dollar in the woods and
underneath were these tremendous nazi
party files
and the ss was there the gestapo was
there and so on so we sent this crew out
to
scour these for incriminating evidence
and outlined
exactly what evidence we're looking for
murder crime devastation beyond military
necessity rape burning destruction
racial you know we didn't use the word
genocide in those days
but they were already trained i was
briefed
worked out a form which they had to fill
out
all the documents what related to the
crime we were trying to prove
because two things were necessary and
this is important and the public doesn't
know it in order to have a successful
war crimes prosecution you need one
evidence beyond a reasonable doubt
that specific
known crimes have been committed
two you need the defendant
if you haven't got both together at the
same time you've got nothing
and to bring the two together was not
easy
you had the evidence you didn't have the
man he was in argentina somewhere you
had the man you didn't have the evidence
you knew he was guilty as hell but you
didn't have the evidence you knew it
from his position but you didn't have it
so this crew which my wife shortly
joined she came over with the first
shipload of wives allowed to come into
germany um
scoured the files uh and
began on the basis of what was coming in
to break down
the type of cases we might conceivably
put together in a short period of time
and we were under a great time pressure
which is often forgotten we had to do
this for a limited budget within a fixed
period of time because the political
scene was changing and we wanted to get
these trials over with
and
the prosecutors
were like me or even worse because i
knew very little about germany uh i
didn't even know the language properly
at the time and the others who came in
from mississippi arkansas wherever they
had some had the funniest idea where
germany was they were sent because they
had a senator friend they wanted to get
rid of them or get him a job or whatever
it was so we had a very mixed crew
of of prosecutors
to decide who is to be tried and on the
basis of which evidence so this process
began between berlin
primarily and nuremberg of coordination
between the two and it was in that
context that this plane was flying back
and forth and we had to parachute out of
one of them would tell for taylor and
his wife and so on but that's another
story uh and they were also we sent out
crews to various parts of vienna to
wherever the nazis were
you know information came in and and
justice jackson had collected a
tremendous amount of information in
paris from captured nazi archives so our
job was to sort out
this tremendous
uh about tremendous i mean you know all
the german records and the germans are
terrific at records they keep everything
in 100 copies except the secret ones
they destroyed the iss group reports we
only found one copy
and to put all this together and
understand them and see how it fits in
and this to be done
by a group of inexperienced young
american lawyers who knew really very
little of anything
about what really happened
so that's the job that we had that's how
we went about that how many months did
you have to do this
the time between
we opened the berlin branch and the time
the first trial went on i don't remember
it specifically now but i would guess we
had three months
something like that before the trial the
first was a doctor's trial three or four
months something like that
uh
and uh ready to go to trial
and submit all the evidence to the
accused let me say a word about the
fairness of the nuremberg trials
because there's been a lot of
misunderstanding about that
justice jackson dealt with it the
international military tribunal which
was the court with the russians and the
french and the british and the americans
uh also dealt with it it's true it was a
trial of the victors only against the
vanquished only we didn't try americans
at nuremberg
and that has subjected us to
i think justified criticism
but the reason for the criticism is that
such trials
are tainted and it's very difficult to
have a fair trial
we tried very hard i think succeeded in
overcoming that taint
by being very careful to make sure that
the trials were absolutely fair and they
were
now you've heard my criticism of the
army trials as a joke
the nuremberg trials were not a joke
they were nor were they unfair trials
they were absolutely fair trials i wrote
an article in the
american journal of criminal law and
criminology on the fairness of the
nuremberg trials
and as clear evidence that it was fair
we gave the defendants all of the
evidence which we intended to use
against them
at least 30 days before trial
the courtroom was open to the public
including the german public
everything was recorded in english and
in german the records were available to
anybody who wanted to read them
the judgments were read in open court
the defendants were all represented by
council of their own choice
which
very often was excellent former nazi
lawyers
they had the kind of trial which is
jackson said they in the days of their
pomp and power never gave to any man
so although
the nuremberg trial had to take a step
forward in some directions to develop
international criminal law and although
they were trials by the victors they
were and although some of the victims
themselves came with dirty hands
nevertheless there was no excuse for the
accused
the fact that uh a member of the jury
was himself a murderer does not excuse
the murderer who sits in the dock
and uh so the trials were very fair
trials and my experience
uh with those trials
as i think
a person who can be objective about it
is that they were the biggest advance in
international criminal law that had ever
been taken to that time
you sat and watched the nuremberg drugs
i sat well i was in berlin working
collecting the evidence and running the
office it was a big office with a lot of
things going on it was the einstein's
group and records for example were found
in the burnt out gestapo headquarters in
the basement one copy out of a hundred
uh
mimeographed copies at that time
recounting
uh chronologically
the murders
in all the towns by these special
extermination squads you cannot even
translate the words einsatzgruppen
and uh
you know you had to have staff to do
that to organize it and defeat it to
make sure we had a trial in fact we were
not scheduling a ninezette's group and
trial we had trials against the high
command we had trials against some ss
offices the uh rice sasha highs helped
them
uh
but we hadn't planned a nine-seater
group in trial
and when i
one of my researchers came in with these
lights folders three or four of them
with all these daily reports from the
front how many jews they had killed in
which towns and the reports would read
you know today we entered the town of so
and so within the first 24 hours we
succeeded in eliminating they never
always use euphemisms in eliminating 14
312 jews 127 communist officials 816
gypsies and they released them you know
and they sent that off to berlin they
were then consolidated from all these
units in the field and issued as a
report
and issued to all the highest echelons
of german government those who said they
never heard of it and didn't know the
foreign office the uh finance ministry
all the ministries we're getting copies
of these reports anyway this researcher
found this and he came in and gave it to
me and i looked at it and i said my god
we have here a chronological listing of
mass murder i got into the next plane
and i flew down to nuremberg and i
presented this to telford taylor who was
the chief of counsel and he had to
decide on what was going to be tried
and he said this is terrific you know
where can we use it i said well look it
says enough for a separate trial by
itself look at here we've got the names
of all the commanding officers there are
three thousand men there we have four
big commandos einstein's group a b c d
and each one with 10 or 12
different
units under them
and
he said we don't have staff anymore for
that
i said you've got to make staff he said
well maybe we can pull somebody off from
somebody else
uh and i said well who if you got it
somebody's got to do it he said well
well could you do it
i said sure i could do it why can't i do
he said well you got your other job you
got to do an additional job i said i'll
do them
i got it all lined up he said if you
want it you got it
and uh so i became then the chief
prosecutor for the united states and
what the united press called the biggest
murder trial in history
22 defendants convicted of murdering
over a million people mostly jews i was
27.
so that's how the war crimes trials were
planned
let me add another interesting point
there were 22 defendants
there were 3 000 german officers and men
who were engaged for at least a period
of two years and doing nothing else but
killing jews and others who were
perceived to be enemies of the raj we
tried 22
and the reason we tried 22
was because we only had 22 seats in the
dark
if we had a 21 we would have tried 21.
we knew that it was only a small
sampling
of those responsible for mass murder on
a daily basis
but that's all that we could do under
the circumstances and our option was to
do nothing but to do that much
and we did and we established the record
we did not punish all the guilty those
22 were convicted 13 of them were
sentenced to death
by judge michael miss mono the supreme
superior court of pennsylvania only four
were actually executed and some of them
are practicing law in germany today
i had the documentary evidence
uh chronicling specifically which units
killed how many people what types of
people in which towns
i had very little staff
i was the chief prosecutor i had
three assistants
the defendants 22 defendants were
entitled to have one or two
defense lawyers of their choice
the best nazis money could buy and they
were very good
i decided that i was going to prosecute
the case
without calling a single witness
and the reason i did that
was because
the documentary evidence spoke for
itself it was absolutely reliable
uh it was their reports from the front
at that time i could have had available
a thousand witnesses any one of whom
would have come in and sworn under oath
that that particular defendant murdered
his mother his father his children and
that he witnessed it
i would had no trouble whatsoever
not that they would all be lying
but that's the way they felt and the dp
camps were all around me and nuremberg
they were all
munich everywhere there were dp camps
and i was in and out of the camps and uh
uh
and i decided i wasn't going to do that
because they would not be telling the
truth they would not be credible
witnesses their own emotions would be
such that their memory would be
distorted and their testimony would be
vulnerable
so i decided to go to trial
on the documents alone never had
happened at nuremberg
and i gave the defendants
all of my records these whole reports 30
days before trial and i said prepare
your defense
when i opened the trial immediately of
course they challenged the validity of
the documents ah they are fake
they're forgeries the russians have
fabricated them the usual you know kind
of business i had been very meticulous
with those files they had immediately
been taken into custody of an american
colonel no one had gotten near those
files he was put on the stand to testify
that he had been responsible they'd been
put in a sack locked on the lock and key
and he'd guarded them
all the time and where they were found
and how they were found identification
so and so very soon it was clear they
were not going to get away with that
excuse
and
after three days
i rested my case
these are the defendants that's the man
olendorf that's his report dated such
and such which says we killed 90 000
jews as of this time there's the
defendant that's the charge that he
killed 90 000 jews and so reported on
this and this date i don't need any more
evidence
that's it and i went down the list and
three days i rested the case no trial at
nuremberg anywhere had been done with
such speed and such economy of means as
general clay or somebody else said to me
then the fun began
you never saw such a pack of lies as
these guys brought out if the report
said on july 12 1941
einstein's commando 10a of which i was
the commanding officer killed 3412
people jews
the commander said
well you know that's with my commando
but
on that day i happen to be at my
grandmother's funeral
in berlin and i show you here is a
report from the funeral pileup from 46
witnesses who saw me there including the
mayor the including the general
including so-and-so and when i got back
what did i discover
i don't know what do you nobody would
tell me what had happened
and here i hear for the first time that
jews were being killed can you imagine
something like that jews were being
killed by my outfit when i wasn't there
i was appalled
you know and they came with excuses
guys who for years have been every day
killing jews had the gall to come and
say i hear it for the first time that
jews were killed you know
and right down the list wherever they
found the document which would put the
noose around their neck they found some
alibi backed up by hundreds of
affidavits witnesses of all kinds
the defense lasted
six or nine months
nine months
uh they came in with all this baloney
and the judge michael mosmano much to my
unhappiness i would say said whatever
evidence they want to submit in their
defense is admissible
he passed what he called the penguin
rule up to and including the sex life of
a penguin it's admissible
and i was furious because the rules of
evidence you know these guys were lying
well i wasn't going to take that
so i called in our investigative
division as we were going along and i
said look these are the defendants this
is their home address this is what we
know about them i want you to go to
their homes
begin on the roof
the chimney tear that house apart until
you've dug up the floor of the basement
and bring me all the evidence that you
have every letter everything that's been
written another crew you start screening
all the information i want to know what
did he write home where was he at the
different times
and sure enough i'd find letters when he
was supposed to be at his grandmother's
funeral
he never had a grandmother she died 50
years before i checked that out too uh
that he wrote home to his wife saying oh
gerda did we have a day today i was
swimming in jewish blood you know and
all the rest of it all the rebuttal and
i had that for a bottle
then i went on with the rebuttal
are you at your grandmother's funeral
where are you yeah what was the name of
your grandmother grandmother so-and-so
when was she born well i don't know
exactly when did she die well she did
that on that day yeah she died in that
day is that the same gyarados also who
died 12 years before
do you have two grandmothers by that
name you know and uh what about delivers
your handwriting did you write this
letter to your wife etc so we went on
with the rebuttal and the rebuttal
lasted six months
uh until we tore this apart and when we
got all through
uh they were all convicted
beyond a reasonable doubt and judge miss
mono
devout catholic
superior court of pennsylvania judge a
respected judge went off into a
monastery for a week
to commune with his conscience and with
his god and with his faith
and he came back and he began reading
the sentences
for the crimes of which you are
convicted this tribunal sentences you to
death by hanging boom and the nuremberg
courtroom if you've seen the pictures of
it the panel door is open the
prisoner steps back the door is closed
and he's dropped down into the prison on
one of these rotating
uh
mariah
elevators and he would disappear the
next one come up for the crimes in which
you are convicted this tribunal sends
you to death by hanging one after the
other bang bang bang 13 times in a row
they chop them down and sends them to
death
uh a very dramatic
most dramatic day
in my life i must say
you interrogated these men
yes
i tried to avoid interrogating them
before trial
because
i had interrogators for that
and i didn't want
to have any
personal feelings
interfere with my judgment of their acts
i wanted them to be tried for what they
did
they could justify themselves on trial
and they did they tried to explain this
was necessary for the good of germany
blah blah blah
uh
and uh the lead defendant
haruholandov
ss brigadier general father of five
children
i went down to talk to him after he was
sentenced to death
in the death house
and i thought well
maybe he wants me to
take a message to his wife or his
children or something like that
and i would have been glad to do that
he justified killing ninety thousand
jews on the grounds it was necessary for
the good of germany
uh and he explained
that uh
uh he was asked why did you kill the
children
and he said well i was interested in the
permanent security of germany and if the
children grew up and they knew i'd kill
their parents they would be enemies of
germany therefore was necessary to kill
them but i always insisted that my men
do it in a humane way if i saw they were
enjoying the work i took them off the
job
and
i instructed them if a woman had an
infant child let her keep the infant
because they could then fire into the
child and kill the woman at the same
time which saved ammunition that was a
much easier way of dealing with it so
you see he was really an idealist and a
humanitarian
so i went down to the death house
underneath the courthouse in nuremberg
and
he was brought by two
big guards american troops
uh into a small cell and i could talk to
him through a small opening
and i asked him whether there was
anything he wanted to say to me or
anything he wanted me to do for him
and he said the jews in america will
suffer for what you have done to me
so there was not the slightest sign of
remorse on the contrary
i'm sure he went to his death believing
that what he did was right that he would
do it again and i saw pictures
of his
burial where his graveside was
surrounded by a large group of nazis
giving the hitler salute the final
greeting to their fallen comrade ss
general otto olandov murderer of 90 000
jews
and
most of the einsatzgruppen
not the order police that went along
with them but the einsteins group and
themselves
were educated oh yes the notion that
these crimes were committed by sadistic
beasts is a mistake
these crimes were led by very well
educated
distinguished
german
cultured citizens
they were kind to their cats and dogs
they could quote goethe they all loved
wagner
and they killed human beings like they
would be flies how do you
how did you make sense of that
makes very good sense
if you begin with a certain premise it
follows quite logically if you begin
that
let us say lice are unhealthy
then you exterminate the lice if you
begin with the premise that certain
types of people whether they be jews or
they be gypsies or they be poles or
whether they be muslims or whether they
be croats or or anything else
are
parasites
uh which represent a threat to a healthy
body then you exterminate them and you
exterminate them completely if you can
so it follows logically and the danger
of course is the premise in which you
begin when you stop and fail to realize
that all human beings should be entitled
to a minimum standard of human dignity
and you begin to consider yourself the
superior race and the others are there
to serve you that's what follows
logically and so most of my life i'm
spending now trying to
change that way of thinking in order to
recognize that all human beings should
be treated as human beings
so education of a wide sort never made
somebody rational except in that logical
way it wasn't well education is is a
process which has many
forms many ways of educating people some
people you can never educate there was
nothing i could have done to change all
industry of thinking nothing and his
others were even worse because they
denied it and they knew it was true
so people either denied it and the few
admitted it and nobody was contrite no
remorse the my biggest pain i think in
in this whole experience was the absence
of remorse
uh they were sorry for themselves
we also suffered what else could you
expect the jews brought it on themselves
this was necessary for the good of the
world
this was a sort of sentiment
almost universal not completely and it
would be unfair to those few people who
felt otherwise and who
tried to do whatever they could to help
so i don't want to
paint a whole nation or whole people
with one brush but it was so widespread
and in my trial one of them had one of
the defendants fellow by the name of
klingelhofer he had the decency to try
to commit suicide unsuccessfully
unfortunately but uh
and he didn't ask for clemency at the
end they left him there till the end and
he was the only one who really showed
any sense of contrition for which i
admired him at least to that extent
but the others
i hear it for the first time i don't
believe it jews happen you're
persecuting me uh what else could i do
you know superior orders was necessary
for the good of the fatherland and all
that
um
it's not easy to educate people
but if you don't try
then we're all in danger you know
everywhere
so i feel you've got to try and that's
what i'm trying to do
let's go back to the fairness issue for
a moment who paid for the defense
attorneys
the defense attorneys were paid for by
the united states
out of occupation funds i must admit but
it was
all expenses were paid the
guest house as we call the place where
the defense counsel had their offices
and witnesses were kept
were
excellent accommodations under the
circumstances at the time they were fed
they got cartons of cigarettes which was
a great demand at the time
all of this at no expense whatsoever to
the defendants the defendants were given
every possible
right of trial and the presumption of
complete innocence and they had to be
found guilty beyond a reasonable doubt
so they were absolutely fair trials if i
ever commit any crimes i hope i get the
same kind of fairness so the subsequent
trials were were conducted under the
same rules of procedure as the nuremberg
the nuremberg judges had no rules of
procedure when they began the charter of
the international military tribunal
defined the crimes and the jurisdiction
of the court but left it to the court
themselves to lay down their rules but
since the judges were all distinguished
jurors the british presiding judge for
example they knew the rules of evidence
they knew what was a fair trial and they
had to merge different judicial systems
the french system for example is quite
different from the american and the
british the russians also quite
different so it was necessary for them
to come up with rules of fairness
which they did they did very well
and at nuremberg we had the benefit of
their rulings to guide us and in
addition we developed our own rules as
we went along all of which were then
published in a big volume by item 15 of
the green series by the united states
government so that this information is
available for use in yugoslavia or other
courts in the future if there are any
such courts and
the fact that the rules didn't exist in
advance didn't mean that the decisions
were unfair to the defendants i felt
they weren't fair to the prosecution
but
after all the defendant is a guy on
trial so i didn't really mind it too
much although i was most annoyed would
never have gotten away in an american or
a new york court with the things which
were admitted in evidence in the adverse
group and trial
can you comment on what became
emphasized and what became de-emphasized
at these trials
and why
it's uh it's not so much a matter of
emphasizing one is against the other
um
the first category that you mentioned
uh crimes against peace
or otherwise known as aggression
that
has been perceived for a long time as
being
as the tribunal said in this case in the
imt trial
the greatest of all crimes because it
encompasses all the other crimes when
you commit a crime against peace an act
of aggression the war that follows
invariably involves
killing large numbers of people and the
rape and the devastation and the
destruction and every crime that you can
imagine takes place in a war
and so committing a war of aggression
is the most serious crime that any head
of state
can commit
this was known after the first world war
and
efforts were made at that time to bring
the kaiser to trial for aggression
against little belgium for example
and this was hotly debated by
international lawyers
the kaiser himself had fled to the town
of dawn in holland
he was known as the woodchup of dawn
the dutch refused to extradite him
because there was no precedent for
trying a head of state for the crime of
aggression
and
the international lawyers who were
dealing with it including americans in
japanese who were then on our side
felt that well all right
in order not to
have retroactive justice
they will not try him for the crime of
aggression
because it had never been declared to be
an international crime
they would charge him in the treaty of
versailles of crimes against the
dictates of the human conscience which
had been referred to in the hague
agreements of 1899
and
but that wasn't good enough because the
head of state had never been tried so
that still refused to turn them over he
never was put on trial
however when we got to nuremberg
justice jackson who was a first class
jurist
said look
the time has come for the law to take a
step forward
the principle of non-retroactivity
is a principle of equity you don't
charge a person with a crime
when he didn't know it was a crime at
the time it was committed
however
did not hitler know
that invading a neighboring state
a friendly neighboring state is a crime
did not everybody in the world know that
so to declare that a crime does not
violate any equitable principle
particularly in the light of all the
presidents we had we had the hague
agreements in 1898 were 1907. we had the
kellogg-briand pact in 1928 saying that
the war is outlawed these packs all had
loopholes written into them but and
jackson was certainly aware of that but
he said look the time has come
and it's nothing unfair about trying
these guys for the crime of a crime
against peace of committing aggressive
war even though aggression was not
defined
and jackson dealt with that in his
opening statement he said look
aggression has not yet been defined in
legal terms but whatever it was this is
it i know an elephant when i see one
and
so he was deliberately taking
the law a step forward to do to keep up
with the common sense of mankind and it
was based upon the long tradition which
had already been established that the
medieval notion of warfare where the
king goes out and kills doesn't apply in
modern times
so that was the first and most important
principle out of the nuremberg
charter
incidentally all of these principles
were then affirmed unanimously by the
united nations general assembly and they
were also affirmed by the tribunal which
examined
the thing and it will tell you in
connection with crimes against humanity
they interpret a very restricted way the
second one was the crimes against
humanity
that
connotation had never existed before
uh
and the theory behind it was that when
crimes reach a certain magnitude
that they shock the conscience of
humankind
they are crime not merely against the
state
which happens if somebody murders
somebody in new york it's the state of
new york again so-and-so defendant but
it's a crime against all of humanity and
therefore humanity as the injured party
has the right to be the plaintiff and
can bring the charges for that crime
that also was a step forward
but it was not an unfair step forward it
was a necessary step forward if you were
going to have a civilized international
society and the medieval notions which
were perfectly okay but perhaps when the
king lived behind the castle wall didn't
apply so crimes against humanity was
another step forward the third category
war crimes that was a cinch
the hager graves 1899 had defined what's
permissible in warfare what's not and a
violation devastation beyond the needs
of military necessity rape plunder uh
poison gas things of that kind these
were well-established crimes they
presented no problem
now there was
a restriction put on by the
international military tribunal the
tribunal itself in reviewing its own
jurisdiction said look we have the right
as lawyers
as international lawyers of of great
repute
they were key people from all the
countries
to examine the charter and see whether
the charter is
an exercise in
creating new law or whether it is a
legal instrument which we are bound by
and they said it's a legal instrument we
are bound by
uh because it enunciates principles of
law which should be binding and which
are binding law but
they said because of the wording of the
statute
and it was an accident really someone
put a semicolon in and i won't go into
the detail in order for there to be a
crime against humanity it must also be
linked with one of the other crimes
crime against peace
and that meant
that
the killing of large numbers of people
without a war
would not be a crime against humanity
would not be within the jurisdiction of
the court and that's what they held
some of us who have been involved were
shocked at that interpretation
we said that's wrong we didn't have that
in mind you mean to tell me that if
hitler kills all his jews and he's not
at war with anybody else that is not a
punishable offense
that's what the tribunal said under this
charter we cannot act
so we changed that
we changed that very specifically by a
control council law the governing
agency for all of germany at that time
was a control council consisting of the
four powers soviet union france the
united states
and uh
patel about uk
and this control council enacted control
council law number 10 which corrected
that and said very specifically crimes
against humanity are not linked to any
other crimes
and that meant
that if you
killed your own nationals and the crimes
were of such magnitude as to shock the
conscience that was not more clearly
defined then it becomes a crime against
humanity which is a different
international criminal offense
and that was then confirmed in the
einsatzgruppen case while i was pushing
on that one and in one other case the
subsequent trials
so that today despite the confusion
which exists among many international
lawyers who write big books on this
subject the fact is
that it is the legal right
of nations to intervene
to stop crimes against humanity and i
think it's a legal duty on their part to
intervene to stop crimes against
humanity and that has tremendous
consequence
for
the development of a peaceful
and law-abiding international society
quick lecture
sorry
can you talk some about the review of
all of these cases and
and what happened to the sentences yes
let me let me uh again clarify what has
been a frequent misunderstanding
i'm not talking now about the army
trials of dachau
when the trials were declared to be over
by the pentagon because they didn't want
the budget everybody went home and all
was forgiven and that was the end of
that
um those who were still in prison i
don't remember if they served some did
serve the sentence and and some of them
were were hanged after that but i mean
the trials themselves ended
the subsequent proceedings under the
direction of general telford taylor
and there were 12 such trials
had to be reviewed
first by general clay
uh who reviewed them and conf affirmed
the sentences as being fair and correct
but the death sentences
had to
have a special order written out
directing that the men be executed
uh there were about
15 or 16 death sentences pending of
which 13 came out of my hindsight's
group in trial
when john mccloy came in as high
commission to replace general clay
general clay apologized to him for not
having taken gotten rid of this nasty
business
because there was an appeal pending
before the u.s supreme court and he
couldn't act until that was settled
the appeal was rejected by the supreme
court of the united states and the lot
fell to mccloy
mccloy
had been the assistant secretary of war
during world war ii
uh he was a very distinguished uh
establishment lawyer from new york
originally been from
uh philadelphia
and um
he knew nothing really about you know
the specifics of the trials or of those
particular accused he was familiar with
the overall trials and had in fact
supported them in the department of the
army uh when he was the assistant
secretary of war
and
so he had his legal department
study all of these records
and he did something else he appointed a
three-member panel
uh
a clemency board to review the
cases and make recommendations as to
what should be done and the members of
those board the principal officer was
judge peck of new york who i think is
jewish
and there was one man from the state
department
and there was one who was a a
professional penalogist
and
their instructions were to go over these
files
their specific instructions which is not
generally known
which i dug out later there was secret
at the time
said you are not to review
the correctness of the decisions in any
case
that has already been determined and is
binding
the only thing you ought to examine
are the personal circumstances of each
defendant such as his health his family
condition or differences in the severity
of sentences for the same crime so that
if one got off easy one got 20 years the
other got 10 years for the same crime
you would recognize that as being
inequitable and make a recommendation to
bring that into the line
it was not and i repeat not a
pardon committee
they had no jurisdiction whatsoever on
the contrary to challenge the validity
of any of the decisions of the tribunals
of nuremberg
not generally known the pec panel as
they would got to be called
sat down in munich and began to go over
some of these files i happened to be in
nuremberg at the time running the
restitution programs beginning to set
them up i wrote to the pec panel i wrote
to peck and the others and i said look
gentlemen i know you're here with a very
difficult job
uh i was executive counsel then to tell
for taylor for all of the trials and
then another additional job that i took
on
and uh
uh i said uh i uh i'm thoroughly
familiar with all of the trials
and should you require any information
or any assistance in any way i'm at your
service
they wrote back in a letter which will
go to the national archives which i just
recently uncovered
saying thank you very much but no thanks
we're only going to hear from the
attorneys for the defendants
we don't want to hear from any attorneys
for the prosecution
[Music]
surprised me at the time and
annoyed me at the time i must say
and so the pec panel met they had a few
meetings together in munich is a lovely
city they can travel all around southern
bavaria to austria from there and they
did spent the summer that way and then
they made their recommendations to mr
mccloy
and
he then together with general handy who
was dealing with the military some of
the leftover daha trials
they issued a clemency report
which i will give to the holocaust
museum which i'm sure you'll find in the
archives
in which
they confirmed
three or four of the death sentences
commuted the rest
usually to life imprisonment
lowered the sentences on some defendants
uh the only defendant against whom
uh there had been a judgment or
forfeiture of all of his assets was the
multi-billionaire alfred krupp they gave
him back all of his assets
and
that was that
that evoked a tremendous outcry of
protests from the nazi victims and from
the jewish organizations and from
general telfer taylor
and as a result
mr mccloy
has not been in the good graces of
either the nazi victims or the jewish
organizations
now i feel
and i've given the documentation to the
holocaust memorial museum our will
that mr mccloy got a bum rap
that uh
he was unfairly judged
he was criticized including in a book by
william manchester called the arms of
crook
uh which attacked mr mccloy in a very
harsh way i think
for
having released mr krupp from prison and
having given him back his very sizable
fortune
uh mccloy was condemned as having done
this as an act of political expediency
in order to woo the germans back into
the allied camp so they could be
re-armed to help fight against the
russians the soviets
i am absolutely convinced that was not
mr mccloy's motive
and the reason i am convinced of that is
simple
i'm a man who looks at the documents
uh and before i talked to mccloy about
it i looked at the documents i found his
instructions to the clemency board and i
found with great difficulty the clemency
board's recommendations which were
secret
and in the instructions i've indicated
the instructions were you are not to
challenge these verdicts we are not
reviewing the validity of these
sentences or of these judgments we are
only taking into account humanitarian
considerations which may be applicable
then when the clemency board
recommended
reduction of sentences for various
people
mccloy
checked all those recommendations and in
many cases mccloy was more harsh than
the clemency board had been
and i drew up a table which i gave to my
friend telford taylor who was in my law
partner had been for many years
and i said look here
if this man is trying to do something as
an act of political expediency all he
has to do is to accept the clemency
board's recommendations they're
independent people
uh or he can accept the german arguments
that death penalties have been outlawed
in germany under the constitution and
are no longer applicable or accept the
pleas of the various german peace groups
and the religious groups and the
anti-nazi groups who are besieging him
and mrs mccloy to please don't hang
these people
instead of that he ordered four of them
to be hanged
uh which he didn't have to do and he
increased the sentences on several
others
a man who's determined to win the favor
of germany either he's a damn fool to do
that
or he has other motives and i am
convinced that his motivation was
humanitarian it was sincere i know from
having seen him very frequently during
that period that he was torn by emotion
uh and having to go over this he had
never caused anybody to be hanged before
and it was not an easy thing for him
and so the harsh criticism that he was
merely warning the german at the expense
of the jews is a mistake i know that
also the help he gave us in connection
with jewish restitution and the
statements that he made to the germans
and the pressure he put on the germans
to see that they paid more than they
wanted to pay
why do you think he's received such a
round just because people have not
investigated it well it's easy to
criticize and it fits into a preset
pattern you know the americans are
warning the germans in order to get them
to fight the russians that's the
manchester pattern
and
it should be examined you know in that
light and many people share that view
but it's a political opinion not based
on fact
and mccloy has also been criticized for
not bombing the rail lines at auschwitz
and i discussed that with him at some
length
uh long after the event i did not
intrude on him in what i recognized to
be a personal
uh decision that he alone had to make
about the life and death of other people
and i felt that was something which
should not be a result of political
pressure and when i discussed with him
the bombing of the rail lines i said
look you realize that the
jewish community is in
an uproar because of your failure to do
that and
what was going through your mind and he
said it was very simple
first of all
the british who were anti-semitic
uh
didn't want to
because they didn't want to divert their
bombers
from winning the war which they
perceived to be the primary goal
and we had to use british bombers for
that kind of an operation because we
divided our responsibilities such as
such and he said i had long discussion
with ben rosenman who was the
president's jewish advisor roosevelt's
jewish advice in the white house at that
time about this whole issue
and there were also strategic reasons
first of all
you'd have to bomb them from a height
where it was almost inevitable you're
going to hit the inmates
if you start bombing
the barracks of inmates
uh what is going to be the response
politically on the united states bombs
uh jewish inmates or the other inmates
in auschwitz
and he said it was another strategic
consideration
bombing rail lines a waste of time
because they can be repaired immediately
you bomb a few miles of rail lines so
what
uh they come with a rail train they put
a few rails down so you've laid them for
an hour or two isn't going to change
anything other country they'll start
killing them faster he said so in my
judgment he said not only my judgment he
said ben roseman so he took this up in
the highest level that was not the thing
to do it was not in the interest of the
nazi victims to do it they want to give
me the wrap let him give me the rap and
i said look would you like to talk to
them he said no
he said no
and
you know i had a long discussion later
with him about the crook clemency action
and the releasing of krupp and uh i
persuaded him that he'd made a mistake
and he sent me a note and he said if i
knew then what i know now
i've written less than slaves and given
more material he said i
would probably have done it differently
and i said can i publish that he said
not as long as i'm alive
i will now give that information to the
holocaust memorial museum and you've got
it on tape
next weekend on sunday november 22nd
we'll air part two of this interview
with benjamin ferenz
in the second part he talks about the
war crimes trials and how prosecutors
collected evidence against nazi leaders
he also discusses how the united states
dealt with restitution toward jewish
families who survived the holocaust
in november 1945 war crimes trials began
in nuremberg germany for major nazi
figures a subsequent trial called the
einsatzgruppen case involved 24 nazi ss
defendants accused of killing more than
a million people for the 70th
anniversary of the nuremberg trials
c-span's american history tv is airing
an oral history interview with benjamin
franz former united states chief
prosecutor in the einsett's group in
case mr ferenz was born in transylvania
to a jewish family and immigrated to
america when he was an infant he
enlisted in the u.s army after earning
his law degree and was later assigned to
set up a war crimes branch to
investigate nazi atrocities
next in part two of his interview he
discusses the war crimes trials and how
prosecutors collected evidence against
nazi leaders he also discusses how the
u.s dealt with restitution towards
jewish families who survived the
holocaust this is the second of a
three-part interview and was conducted
by the united states holocaust memorial
museum in washington dc it's about an
hour and a half
ben i wanted to go back a little bit to
the beginning of the uh
be you're being put on the war crimes
teams that were going and collecting
evidence were there any rules
in the beginning there were no rules
whatsoever because the persons who were
sending us out had not the foggiest idea
what we were supposed to do
i mean we knew we were supposed to do
something in connection with war crimes
trials
but as an attorney
i of course knew the rules of evidence
and what was required i had been
interested in criminal law particularly
and of course i knew that
what constitutes
admissible evidence in a court of law
and we were trying of course to collect
that kind of evidence in order to make
the convictions hold up
so there was nothing
so how did you make up these things i
mean
well we had to improvise as we went
along uh i mean we didn't have a regular
courtroom where you could call in a
witness and uh
examine him with a secretary present and
someone else cross-examining or
securing his rights we
if we were taking testimony from
friendly witnesses we'd take an
affidavit from them they'd swear to it
before an an officer if it was from a
hostile witness um we would interrogate
him privately uh in order to see if we
could ascertain the truth and when we
reached a point where we felt we had
ascertained the truth we asked him to
write it out in his own hand and
subscribe to it as being true
and usually brought in an officer to
witness that
or to
take a separate deposition
uh under more favorable circumstances
from a point of view of trial
and that was the evidence that we then
used
what was it what was the difference
between you and jack knowlets in terms
of
technique or writing reports and
well jack was a much more stable fellow
i would say
he was more cautious in his approaches
but he was more exuberant in his
descriptions
and when he would come upon a
typical concentration camp scene had to
write a report he would say these
sadistic beasts guards were murdering
the people in cold blood and it was
outrageous and a violation of every you
know act of human decency and i would
have to calm him down and say look jack
we're just preparing a legal document to
drop an indictment you refer to the
accused you don't refer to them as the
dirty bastards
you refer to them as the suspected war
criminals and by name and rank and you
don't describe anything in
graphic terms which would prejudice the
person reading that you just describe
the facts
and the facts will speak for themselves
so we had a lot of fun actually together
on that we were good friends but we had
a different approach in some of our
descriptions also in some of our
interrogation methods
now you were alone with him doing this
for the first few months were you
reading each other's reports every day
yes we would uh well it wasn't every day
we didn't get back to report every day
we got back after we've been out in the
field for a bit and we'd come back and
he would compare and i would go we'd
discuss it together we were barrack
mates bunk mates and uh you know what
did you do yesterday and well oh boy did
i saw the guy got this guy right i did
that or that and so of course we would
compare it and the written reports
themselves we have to prepare you know
more carefully was it also very somber
between the two no uh interestingly
enough
it was not
somber in the sense that we never
laughed
it was not a laughing matter we didn't
take this lightly neither of us
but
somehow it was just
getting the job done and uh
there were light moments as well
how did you
prioritize the work or is it just
haphazard totally haphazard um if he was
busy on something i'd take the next case
that came in and went out on that one uh
or three or four would come in usually
these were
allied flyer type cases or atrocities of
killing of hostages in different towns a
mass grave had been uncovered and
he would go out and take one case i'd go
out and take the other one and we'd come
back whenever we were through and we
both happened to be in the office at the
same time we would compare notes more or
less uh that was about it
you said earlier that you thought that
the military tribunals at dachau were
insignificant historically
well yes because they were in the nature
of military commissions based upon
the army standards of court martial this
was the general guide there because they
didn't have any other standards they
were not trying to create new principles
of international law like crimes against
humanity they were dealing with war
crimes they understood war crimes
because war crimes were prohibited in
the in the manual of military conduct
and they knew that war crime was
devastation beyond military necessity it
was uh rape a pillage plunder these were
things which had for many years been
codified as the
rules of warfare but they didn't deal
with questions like aggressive war being
a crime
these were the things which came later
with the international military tribunal
and were generated by the fact that
people like justice jackson as well as
some of the other the the british
distinguished judges and and lawyers who
were represented on that uh these were
people who were familiar with the
broader principles and concepts of
international law and international
justice whereas in the army it was just
like uh you know another gi trial where
you bring in the accused he's
represented by another officer or
another individual and the
the judges happen to be
army officers who are available to hear
the case
um could you describe an incident that
happened to you at
matthausen when you walked in to collect
evidence well there were many incidents
at mount house and i suppose that you
are referring to a particularly dramatic
one
which i've mentioned in other contexts
um
coming into a camp was always chaotic
the
bodies were strewn all around the place
the troops were chasing the germans or
the inmates had captured the germans
were busy beating them or killing them
and
you know people were dying all around
and
what i would do as a matter of procedure
i was immediately trying to seize the
records of what had happened in the camp
and every camp had an office a
schreibstuber a writing office and what
i would do was immediately go to the
schreibstuber and try to find out who
was in charge there what was there and
sees whatever would be relevant for war
crimes prosecution and when i came to
the schreib schtub in mount houston
there was an inmate there who was a
shriver as they called him
and there was a favorite position in
fact in the camp if you would be in the
hospital or in the tribe to war in the
kitchen
and he said oh i've been waiting for you
and he said come with me and i recall
going out with him to the
electrified fence and his digging up a
box of records which he had kept
uh and uh
those records
uh
were the records of
all of the ss men the identification
cards who had entered that camp
uh and who had left the camp and had
their photograph on it
it had their
identifying
numbers and addresses date of birth
things of that kind
and he was supposed to destroy
each one of those records before a new
one was issued or when the man left the
camp and he didn't do that which meant
that every time he saved one of those
records and there were hundreds of them
he put his life in jeopardy
and he was ready to do that
hoping and knowing that one day there
would be a day of retribution uh and he
saved those records for that day so to
me it was a reflection of
human hope and uh confidence and faith
you know
uh and courage which was uh very moving
and dramatic for me
now there was some other incident which
happened here a few weeks ago i never
knew who that man was i admired his
courage
and his faith but i never knew who he
was and when i wrote about that in my
book less than slave i said he was a man
whom i didn't know
and then a few weeks ago i received a
letter from a professor at the
university of paris the american
university of paris professor pike
who had written a book
and in that book he had described
i think the book was called the servants
of stalin or in the service of stalin he
had described how
communists had gone to spain
and had fought uh on the side of
liberating forces and when they were
defeated by franco
they had fled into france when the
germans occupied france the germans
seized them and sent them to the mud
housing concentration camp to be killed
or worked to death
one of those persons was in the service
of stalin according to the book
was the man
who handed me those records
and professor pike identified him and
identified him by name and identified
another man in the camp who sent regards
uh
who is now in pepino in france who had
been also collecting and hiding
the
death books registering the uh
exceptional deaths which took place in
the camp listing the names of all the
persons who had been killed by unusual
means
and those files were also turned over to
somebody who signed on behalf of the
commanding general of third u.s army apo
403
and that's the way i signed most of my
receipts i signed whatever was
convenient but uh i asked him to see if
he could get a copy of that record which
the man apparently had kept with him all
these years
so
here 50 years later we have the
coincidence coming out of the blue
the identification of the man who saved
those records and one of his close
buddies
let's go to after the war crimes
trial
and presumably you're going to come back
home what happened well as the nuremberg
trials wound down the einstein's group
and trial was over
i was engaged in two activities
one was
turning our records over to the germans
in the hope and expectation that they
would continue with war crime trials
you'll remember that we only had a very
small sampling for example in the
einsatzgruppen case we had 3 000 men who
were engaged in killing jews for two
years every day and uh we only tried 22
of them because does the number of seats
we had in the courtroom but what about
the rest we had records we knew who they
were we knew
where they had been and
it was material not only in that case
but all of the other 12 subsequent
trials had many residual fallouts and
so we set up at nuremberg what we call
the special projects division
my wife gertrude was engaged in that
activity as well
and the object was to turn those files
over to the germans and we negotiated
with the various german uh prosecuting
agencies to see if they would take those
files and act on them in addition to
that we were trying to publish the
records of the nuremberg trials what
subsequently came out as the green
uh the green series of the 12 subsequent
trials and i was engaged in that as an
editor right at the very beginning and i
think my wife was also working on that
we also incidentally had a complete
german text which was never published
unfortunately which may be around
somewhere in the pentagon but the army
decided it would be too expensive and
had no useful purpose and so they nixed
it at the last moment it was never
published
so i was doing this wrapping up thing
and looking forward to going back to
resuming a normal life and starting a
law practice in new york that was my
intention
one day
i had a visit
from a man who was the
general counsel to the american joint
distribution committee this is the
jewish organization which was the most
active and the leading one the only one
at the time and assisting the dps in the
camps providing assistance to jews
throughout the world not in the united
states who needed it at that time it was
all in germany and their headquarters
was in paris and the director was a man
by the name of dr joseph schwartz
and the council said would i come to
paris and they'd like to talk to me and
i came to paris and he said look
we have a problem and we'd like you to
help us with that problem
and the problem is this that
the jewish organization had succeeded in
persuading the us government
to enact a law providing for the
restitution
of property which had been stolen or
confiscated or taken by duress from the
jews or from others
uh because the restitution law covered
not only jews
and
one provision of that law was that
the airless property
or the unclaimed property which had been
taken from those who were no longer
there to file a claim
should also be restored
now normally if a person dies airless in
the state of new york or anyplace else
the property as chiefs as they call it
passes to the state
but there's a principle of law which
says that you may not be the beneficiary
of any unlawful act if you murder your
wife you cannot inherit her property
if you murder the jews the state which
is responsible can hardly be
the proper recipient of the als property
and so military government as a matter
of military law don't forget germany
surrendered unconditionally and the only
government there was the military
government originally quater apartheid
the four powers later split up but each
in their zone the united states was
responsible for the military government
law in the u.s occupied journal zone of
germany and military government law
number 59 said that a successor
organization shall be appointed to
recover the airless jewish property the
jewish restitution successor
organization
and
the jewish organization which succeeded
in getting that into the law didn't know
where to begin
so they
cried about and uh
they said
benny we would like you
to be
the guy who sets this up
you know your way around germany you
know what happened to the jews
um i was then
high-ranking makarimak with the u.s army
and this was all military occupation at
the time
we don't think anything will come of it
we said
but we have a moral obligation to try
and of course we don't have any money to
put into this we need our money for
relief of the survivors we have enough
to pay your salary for six months which
was i think i don't know six or seven
thousand dollars all together
and uh would you want to take this for
us
i said well i have to talk to my wife we
were getting ready to go home
and we'd been in germany for about two
years
and uh much longer than we had expected
so i came back to nuremberg and i
discussed it with my good wife gertrude
and she said look
uh it's true you know this business
better than anybody else and if how long
did they say it would take and i said
well they thought it might take two
years oh she said i know you it'll only
take one year so
all right so we'll stretch it a little
bit longer and so i agreed to stay
and i designated myself the director
general of the jewish restitution
successor organization
knowing that nothing would impress the
germans more than being a director and
the general
and
so that's how it began
what was the date that uh the jewish
restitution successor organization i was
hired for that job in august 1948
and we had an immediate major crisis
the law required
that all claims be submitted
by the end of that year the end of
december 48th
that was i had about three months
four months
in which
to find staff
find funding
train staff
locate the property submit the claims on
long forms because this was uh
the first step in a long judicial
process
well the first thing i did then was to
recognize that was impossible
so as soon as i agreed to undertake the
job i resigned from nuremberg
and i went to see
the commanding general who was general
lucius clay
who was the commanding general for all
u.s forces in germany then stationed in
berlin
i'd known general clay from before
because i'd been
head of the
branch in berlin that had been
collecting the evidence for the trials
and i went up to see him and i said i've
got this problem and i need an extension
of the law
i said i can't locate all the
confiscated jewish properties hundreds
of thousands of properties of all kinds
all over germany in three months time
with no staff no money no nothing
um
and we discussed the problem and he said
no i don't want to extend the law
because the sooner we get this problem
over with the better off we're going to
be
this will be a thorn in germany's side
and
i don't want to extend the restitution
law
i said all right tell you what we'll do
i'll make a deal with you
uh i will try to get it done and i will
only come back to you
if it's impossible
but i will try
but in order to get it done i need money
first of all i need staff
well he said well didn't the
organizations know that when they wanted
to get this written into the law that it
would cost money to do that i said you
can't ask the jewish organizations which
are now spending every penny they can
raise
to save the lives of these dps to move
them out of here and to rescue them to
put money into
trying to get restitution of jewish
property uh
i said i think that we can take the
money out of occupation funds
the united states army was running on
occupation funds which meant the germans
treasury printed money and we used the
money to pay for whatever we needed he
said you know i can't get occupation
funds because that requires quadruped
approval the russians are going to have
to agree they'll never agree to using
money for uh private property claims he
said i don't think the french will agree
and i don't think the british will even
agree
and i can't do it on my own
so i said well i have another
proposition let me borrow the money from
the american segment
of the occupation funds and when i get
restitution i'll repay the money he said
can i do that legally i said i have a
memorandum here which says you can't he
said well okay if you say it's legal if
i can do it go down and talk to my
finance man and tell him that it's okay
and whatever money you need to get going
but get going but i want to get this
program over with
so i went down and i talked to a
guy in charge of finance and i said i've
just come from the general and we're
setting up a big restitution program
here we got a big rush job and i need
enough funds to get this thing going he
said how much do you need and i said a
million marks
okay sign here
million mark was a hell of a lot of
money
uh
and um
i signed here i was always ready to sign
i signed promising to repay
and um with that money i immediately
went out and hired a tremendous staff
german investigators i requisitioned
cars from the army using my old army
authorizations as a war crimes
investigator i immediately seized every
jeep every car could grab from any motor
pool
and sent investigators into every real
estate registry in germany with
instructions to copy down the names of
any jewish name transferred property
since 1933. very often the germans had
been very helpful to us and they had
stamped a j on the property meaning you
the jew
so you could identify it but we was a
jewish name including alfred rosenberg
and it's true we claimed the property of
the big nazi leader alfred rosenberg the
instructions were you bring it in uh and
we're going to rush to get these claims
out on a big complicated form
and then we set up i set up in nuremberg
there were a club which was occupied by
latvians
and they were mostly drivers now i know
the latvians many of them the estonians
have been very busy killing jews before
they retreated with the germans and were
captured by the americans and then used
by the americans so i said we'd throw
them out of that building i need it for
restitution and bango i moved him out i
moved my furniture from the courthouse
in nuremberg as a prosecutor across the
street to this latvian club
and uh we set up there a big hall it was
a dance hall whatever it really was with
tables right touching each other
typewriter on every table requisition of
borders seized from somewhere and 24
hours a day
we filed claims
as they came in
uh from the field as the investigators
came in they brought the
claims in we had secretaries sitting
there typing
i took an eight-hour shift saw kagan who
was then my deputy the first guy i hired
took an eight-hour shift another man by
the name of george weiss dr george weiss
who came from the jdc in paris and laid
ahead of the austrian operations he
handled the third shift
and
about the day the filing deadline
we loaded all the claims into u.s army
ambulance which i had requisition
somewhere and there was a claims center
where we had to file these claims and we
took this ambulance and drove it up to
the claims center and filed i think it
was 173 000 claims for 173 000 pieces of
property in the american zone of germany
and i called up lucious clay and i said
we don't need an extension we filed
everything
so that's how that's we've submitted the
claim but of course that was only the
beginning of the process
um
the system which was set up was that a
person who felt
that he had been forced to sell his
property under duress
or had had confiscated
was authorized to file a claim setting
down all the facts that then went to a
restitution agency special
judicial type agencies they weren't
really courts
to deal only with these claims and they
would hear the counter claims because
the person who bought it would say hey
wait a minute uh i paid fair value for
it because my friend mr cohen was the
neighbor next door i wanted to help him
escape so i gave him a hundred thousand
marks the property wasn't even worth
more than eighty thousand and as a
result of that he escaped he sent me
three letters when he was in brooklyn i
don't know where he is now but he'd pull
out the letters and so on and he didn't
file the claim because he felt fairly
treated who are you to come here and
claim this property or they said look i
bought the property it was bombed out
it's only a ruin i put on a new roof uh
the roof cost me more than the property
was worth or there was a mortgage on the
property who paid i paid off the
mortgage who's going to give me back the
mortgage money
and then the process began or there were
two or three claimants some of the
in and they claimed some
other other person said they had bought
it in between or it had passed through
several hands it was a complicated
legal process which began
and
if any party was not satisfied with the
decision of the restitution agency they
could go to the restitution court that
was the part of the regular judicial
system from there they could file an
appeal to the appellate branch of the
judicial system in germany german courts
and then there was a final court of
restitution appeals which was composed
originally of allied judges later it was
mixed uh american judges who sat on the
court of restitution appeals and they
would hear
the legal arguments
and the factual arguments in all of
these cases before rendering a final
binding decision
their decisions were all published i
have them and i've given them to the
holocaust memorial museum
and so this long legal process began and
for that we needed lawyers
when we got the property back
we needed people who would manage it we
needed people to repair it we had
businesses hundreds of businesses of all
kinds
which had to be managed and run
and for all of this we had to train
people it was never happened before in
history
and we couldn't trust the germans we
would have to be very careful i had
access to all the nazi party files we
hired nobody without a security check
which meant you had a very limited
selection because we had about nine
million nazi party files in berlin to
which i had free access
so it began and it was a very
interesting legal process from one point
of view to try to create precedence
if i may give you a few legal questions
which came up very early on
uh let me just make two or three to show
you how
history might have been quite different
with a few wrong decisions
the first key issue we had
was at what rate of exchange
do you have to repay
the principle of law is simple
if a person enters into a contract under
duress
when that duress is removed he has the
option of
undoing the contract but he has to give
back what he got and he gets back what
he gave these are the principles of law
which i learned at harvard their
principles of equity and they are not
something invented by military
government they should be applicable and
they are april in one way or another in
all civilized societies
but what happened was
that when the property was transferred
in 1937 or 38
let's assume the jewish owner received a
hundred thousand reich mark for it
by
1949 and 50
the reichsmark no longer existed
it was a deutsche mark and the deutsche
mark was converted at a ratio of ten to
one
so he received a hundred thousand reich
mark and he was giving back
ten thousand deutsche mark
um
and the german said wait a minute
i gave you a hundred thousand marks you
now give him back 10 000 marks
if the jewish owner had been required to
give back a hundred thousand marks he
would say property's not worth it i'm
not going to put money into germany this
beat up old building there which has
been bombed most likely um pay back a
hundred thousand reichsmarks
deutschmarks uh which was
then you know an awful lot of money they
didn't have the money for one thing
would have been completely different
and i had a lot of problems with this i
took this case to the court of
restitution appeals for the first
adviser opinion before we began the
program
and the issue was who bears the burden
of the loss
is it
the victim the jewish victim didn't have
to be jews the victim of nazi
persecution or is it the nazi
or the german
uh didn't have to be a nazi who acquired
the property
and to my mind
the risk of the currency devaluation
should not rest with the victim who sold
under duress it should rest with the
person who acquired the property just as
if he had kept his money in the bank he
would have had it devalued
and that opinion prevailed
if the opinion had gone the other way
there would have been no restitution
program in germany practically none
give you another case
a very dramatic case
the german jews had mostly fled they
were organized in what's called germain
congregations in germany every town had
their own commander or congregation
these are legal entities in germany they
are
anybody who would
as a member of a congregation has to pay
taxes to the state and the state then
supports the congregation out of these
funds the german jewish congregations
had all been dissolved the property had
been seized uh property consisted of old
age homes schools cemeteries buildings
of various kinds large buildings
and the previous owners were scattered
all over the world they were in israel
they were in the united states they were
in chile they were in argentina they
were in shanghai wherever they could
find refuge
but some small groups had reconstituted
themselves they came into munich
very few of them had been members of
that congregation before they came from
poland they came from
russia they came from other places
wherever they were and they
reestablished themselves and said we are
now the congregation
some of them having been
forced to survive using all kinds of
means
were less than the most
honorable or creditable people
let's put it bluntly some were a bunch
of crooks
as confirmed by they're being arrested
from time to time on various charges
and they said we are the owners for
example the munich they said look we
have set up a new congregation we are
claiming restitution of the property
and i said hold on
uh you are not claiming restitution of
property because i'm the successor
organization the jrso jewish restitution
success organization is designated by
military government law
they said no this is our congregation we
are entitled to the synagogue the old
age home the cemeteries whatever it was
and some of them are very valuable
properties
make a long story short
i argued that case in the court of
restitution appeals
and i remember it quite dramatically
because i addressed the three american
judges whom i had known from before
and i said i please the court
i stood on this spot and it was
literally the same spot and argued
against
the nazis for the press prosecution of
the nazis
who had murdered the jews
i never thought i would stand here and
argue against the jewish community
but i have to
because
those who are entitled cannot speak for
themselves
and i made the argument that uh
uh
those who were entitled were scattered
everywhere and we couldn't give the
assets to a small self-proclaimed group
who were not subject to any kind of
controls which we were of course as a
charitable organization under military
government control in the first place
under control of all the world's jewish
organizations in the second place and i
won the case it was known as the
augsburg case because it was against the
augersberg community
some of those who argued against me
ended up in jail
but
there again if that case had gone the
other way
all the jewish properties in germany
which had belonged to congregations
would have been dissipated and would
have disappeared so we had several cases
like that
which were
decisive on how this program was to be
carried out
and
we had good luck i think well more than
good luck i think we were on the right
side
in being able to carry out that program
for the recovery of thousands of pieces
of airless
and unclaimed jewish property
i don't want to run on too long but if
you would like me to give you some of
the difficulties we encountered with
that program i think it may be of jewish
historical interest because in the end
we had to surrender
and we did it in an interesting way
what happened because of some of these
problems of currency conversion and
because
the germans resented
understandably resented having to give
up their homes which they had lived in
for their businesses which they had
acquired and had changed over the years
in many ways in which they had invested
all kinds of things and there were no
substitutes i mean you know housing was
in great demand
and so there was fierce resentment
against this strange organization which
comes along and uh
insists upon taking the property back
and paying only a small fraction of what
had been given for the property
uh or had been outright confiscation
paying nothing because very often
whatever the jew got was taken from him
by
discriminatory taxes of various kind and
i said i'm sorry you collect that from
the german government you don't collect
it from me that you'd ever got it
so it got to be a very very bitter
business
and it was generating anti-semitism in
germany which didn't need to have any
anti-semitism generated in the immediate
post-war
hitler years
and i could see that it would take a
long time
meanwhile the jews were being moved out
of germany
from the dp camps to israel which itself
was destitute it was at war
and there was no place to put them
they were in prefabricated in in in
us army pyramidal tents which attempt
the size of a room which would have 15
army cuts in it
no water
put in open
fields
and this was a situation which called
for immediate action
and i had to generate money at once
by every possible means and so i had to
devise new techniques which i'll tell
you about in a moment
let me give you a specific example
of the type of problem
there was a case that i recall
where
a woman
had acquired the home
of a jewish neighbor
i don't remember was 1937 38 somewhere
around there maybe even earlier than
that
um and
no claim had been filed except by the
jewish restitution success organization
we asserted the claim
she made the usual arguments i was
helping my jewish neighbor what do you
want who are you
we said never mind
move
uh we're going to give you back one
tenth of what you paid
now it so happened that she was the aunt
of an american army general
who not only was an american army
general he happened to be the commanding
general
of the district in germany it was
baden-wurttemberg in which she lived
and he called me up
and he said what the hell do you think
you're doing
my aunt was no nazi she helped her
jewish neighbor
and they didn't file a claim because
they were grateful to her and how do you
come off here filing a claim and
demanding that she get out of her house
and your big deal you're offering her
one-tenth of what she paid for it
and i said sir
i'm here to carry out the law
that's what's provided in the law
and i think the law is correct
i negotiate with your answer and
negotiate with others we try to reach a
settlement
we try to be fair in our settlements
and not to
adhere to the last
drop of blood of the pound of flesh
we make the same offer to your hand
she refuses i will simply carry out the
law which is a military government law
if you may recall
and i am the director general of that
organization appointed by military
government to carry out that law and
that's what i intend to do
so please advise your aunt accordingly
he said like hell i will i'll show you
and he called mr mccloy john mccloy who
was then the high commissioner for
germany
mr mccloy got on the phone with me he
said you know i just got a call from
general so-and-so i've forgotten his
name actually
and he's raising holy hell
he says you're persecuting his aunt
you're doing much worse than the nazis
you're trying to throw her out of her
house and all she did was help her
jewish friend
and
he's very distressed
and i said
mr mccloy
as a good lawyer you know very well
a transaction in 1938 was a duress
transaction
and it's voidable at the option of the
person whose property was taken
i am in the shoes of that person and i
exercise that option as i must
to require the transaction be rescinded
which is what i've done
and that is persistent with consistent
with the law and consistent with my
notions of equity and justice and i'm
sure it is with yours
and he said yes i guess it is he said
i'll call up the general and tell him
well
that's what happened eventually i think
we settled with the ant but we had this
problem thousands of times again and
again recurring
and it not only took time
but we
were not getting the money that we
needed for these urgent tasks that i
described of saving lives
and
so i decided to take another approach
and that was to try to sell these claims
to the german government
uh to each state government global
settlements and i went to the
um
lend the president and the finance
ministries in the different german
states in bavaria baden-wurttemberg and
berlin and hesse
and i said look we've got this problem
we are generating a lot of anti-semitism
you don't want anti-semitism by that
time the
people who are in office were anti-nazis
otherwise they couldn't have gotten into
office
um and we've got to solve this problem
and the way i suggest we solve it is
i'll assign the claims to you so that
you're not the beneficiary by way of a
street but then you can settle with them
on whatever terms you feel are right if
you want to give them back the property
that's your business
but you can ask the jews to make that
sacrifice in order to maintain peace in
your land
and the first adjustment we made was
with the land hesse
frankfurt is nearby so it was in
response and a big palace in wiesbaden
there are some funny stories connected
with that which we won't have time to
tell you but uh
that was the first settlement
for 25 million marks it's a lot of money
long before the hague negotiations i
think it was by 1950 51 it must have
been
um
in which the state of hesse agreed to
take by assignment all of the claims for
properties in hess in the land of essa
from the jewish restitution success
organization in exchange for 25 million
marks down now
and then we did that with the other
lender and we went on to berlin
we had a very difficult problem in
baden-wurttemberg the man in charge of
barden-wurttenberg is a man whose name
you will find in your holocaust archives
otto custer
otto kister
was a very
moral and righteous
human being
very strong sense of justice it was very
helpful in connection with arguing the
ig farben appeal
on behalf of slave laborers
and i knew him quite well and i had
great respect for him
and he said i will not accept the
assignment of your claims and i said why
not
he said because
you will carry out
the law as it was intended to be
i cannot i am an official he was then in
charge of them of restitution for this
uh state of bond wordenberg he said i
will not be able to carry it out that
way for political reasons
and it's important that justice be done
and therefore i will not accept your
claims
you do it i said
have pity i can't do it look at the
problems i'm having the expense the time
the aggravation the anti-semitism that
we're causing
no he said you do it i never settled in
baden-wurttemberg we settled every place
else but we fought those cases through
and that's where this general's wife
his aunt was as well
so this is an illustration of not only a
specific problem but a a
a difficult political problem which we
encountered and
an economic problem as well
and we solved it legally by assigning
our claims globally making global
settlements with all of the lender and
then the states went on for many years
some of them complained that they paid
too much
some of them recognized that they had
made a gain
because as the years went by the prices
went up and so on
but by and large it was a fair and
sensible arrangement as i look at it now
in retrospect and it was a way to get
out we had begun on a legal path which
seemed right at the time but found in to
be insurmountable as it went along
so we had many such problems
if you have time i'll tell you some more
let me tell you another problem
which was a very fascinating problem in
a way too
the problem is
how do you
what do you do about jewish cemeteries
um i know nothing about
the orthodox jewish rituals
but i had
enough common sense
to realize that i wasn't going to touch
that subject
without
strict control and guidance by those who
knew more than i were responsible
under the restitution law the jewish
communities were gone
they all had their own cemeteries
every congregation had a local cemetery
and
sometimes it was a significant plot of
land sometimes there were jews buried in
one portion it had not been used for the
other portions
and so i set up a rabbinical council
headed by rabbi herzog the chief rabbi
of israel at that time
rabbi leo beck who was the chief german
rabbi when they were driven out and
there was another german rabbi
who
represented the jewish communities in
germany
and these three were to give me the
guidelines
of what could be done with the jewish
cemetery once it's been restituted
and
my instructions to the staff were we
abide strictly by these rules and the
rules were that
once a jewish cemetery always a jewish
cemetery you cannot do anything with a
land in which somebody is buried even if
a tombstone falls down you must not pick
it up you must leave it lying there
which was a surprise to me of course
because all jewish cemeteries have been
desecrated
but if there is an area where there are
no bodies
then it may be fenced off
and it can be sold providing it's not
sold for a profane purpose
what is a profane purpose well you have
to go back and look in the talmud
well
uh a hospital obviously is not a profane
purpose
a dance hall probably is
a gambling casino certainly is
so
we had to know
what was being sold and for what purpose
it was being sold
let me just take a minute or two for a
very amusing story it seems to me
we had a a situation of a cemetery in
the old town of fulda
fulda is the north of hesse and it's
famous for the fulda gap where all
armies invade it's an old catholic town
lots of churches
and
there was a jewish cemetery in fulda
and it was a large area
and the
social democratic mayor
wanted to use part of the cemetery which
had
was in the center of town by the time
you know the years had passed originally
it was outside the town but oh may have
been 100 years ago when it was started
was now in the center of town quite
valuable piece
and
he said he wanted to use it as a custom
house to build a custom house was right
on the east german border
i inquired with the rabbinical council
as i did very strictly on all such
matters and they said custom house oh
yes that's okay
and i happened to be in new york when i
got a
i was reporting to the board of
directors a very
dramatic telegram they're building the
custom house and they're digging up
bones
well
uh the contract was very clear there was
a certain area which jewish graves were
known to exist that area was to be
fenced off they were going to have a
little memorial park next to it
the cemetery itself had been desecrated
completely
but we were going to have a little park
there with a plaque and the custom house
was to be built in the area on the
blueprint you know where there were no
graves
well that created a major problem
um
and i rushed back to i sent the telegram
to seek seeking immediate injunction
stop all building i'm on my way home
and
when i got to uh
back to i think we were in nuremberg or
frankfurt at the time
um
i said
how far has it come well they had
already had put about four stories on
the building it was a big building
and one portion of it obviously was
seemed to me over the gravesite
and it was just a small area maybe you
know 10 by 15 feet
and i said tear the building down
i said you can't do that
the jewish community came to me and they
said look we have to live in this town
you can't ask me to tear that building
down
i said what the hell do they think it's
a clear breach of contract tear the
building down it's their problem
and uh they said you can't do that i
mean you know maybe on life will be
unbearable so i said well look let me
consult with the rabbinic council
and i consulted with the council and
they went into a meeting in a conference
and they finally came up with a solution
and they said well the torah says that
you may not have anything on a cemetery
except a jewish prayer house
so what you have to do is raise the
building and it's not on the cemetery
i said raise a five-story building
you know a big building
i said they may know more about the
torah but they don't know much about
engineering you can't raise a five-story
building
so we went back to the rabbis and said
better look some more and then some
genius i don't know which one it was
came up with the solution he said aha if
you can't raise the building what you
have to do is you have to build
the
prayer house
under
the building so that the building rests
on top of the prayer house and there is
nothing which says that you can't build
a building on top of a prayer house or
you can't build it on the cemetery
and so
that's an idea so what we did and i to
anybody who ever views this tape i
recommend they go and check it out
um
in the corner of the customs house in
the city of folder
there is a small
room which is a prayer house
built in accordance with specifications
laid down in israel
with inscriptions on the wall in hebrew
with
stained glass windows
and candelabra there is room for a torah
there is an ark but there is no torah
there
um
and that was built
in the basement excavated under the
customs house and it is the world's most
unknown and unused and smallest
synagogue that ever existed and i went
to check up on that 10 years later
and i came to the
customs house and i said to the
concierge the portuguese there and i
said i want to visit the
synagogue
and they said well you go outside and
you go down turn to the left three
blocks then you turn to the right three
blocks and jewish synagogue i said no no
i want to see the synagogue in this
building
and they said this building is the
custom house
and i said there better be a synagogue
in this building
we'll call somebody and then they called
somebody upstairs and he came running
down he said oh yes yes yes yes and he
had a bunch of keys and he took me down
into the basement and he kicked some
boxes away from the front of the door
and he opened the door
he said this is what you're looking for
that's it and i went in and i inspected
it you know and
was still there and i said anybody ever
used this he said no never has anybody
ever been in here he said no never i
said you keep it clean he said yeah oh
we keep it clean i said fine thank you
very much keep on doing it
so
go to visit the customs house in folder
and check up for me they are bound to do
that forever
now let me tell you another story about
forever because this is a very serious
matter and um
how long is a cemetery to be maintained
one of the things we worked out with the
germans was that they would be
responsible for the maintenance of the
jewish cemeteries
now under german law a cemetery is
maintained for only 20 years
the system there is every town has their
own cemetery and everybody who's a
resident of that town is entitled to be
buried in that cemetery
and they go one after the other as you
die you're put in the in a row in a
small place very orderly the germans are
very orderly people and after 20 years
you're required to take away the
tombstone or you can they'll take it
away for you and they put somebody else
on the same spot saves ground saves
money and i guess it saves some
emotional sentiment after 20 years they
say stop grieving
well
they were quite prepared to do that but
as we were reaching the end of the
20-year period
uh they said now you take care of the
cemeteries
i said wait a minute
jewish law requires a cemetery to
maintain forever
they said forever
cost money you got to cut the grass if
you have a fence around it
you have to you know it's cost money
we're not going to pay that if you have
this peculiar ritual
we're not bound by that why should we
treat you better than we treat our own
well it got to be a very emotional
argument a very dramatic argument
because i just come back from auschwitz
and uh
anyway the germans were finally
persuaded to accept the jewish ritual
and they do maintain the cemeteries in
germany in perpetuity
this was also part of the restitution
program
things that public doesn't know anything
about
how did you convince them
i convinced them by slamming on the
table the bones i had brought with me
from auschwitz
tell me something about the cultural
restitution
since the jewish restitution successor
organization jrso or the germans called
it irso uh was authorized to
claim all
unclaimed or airless jewish property
it also
recovered
thousands many thousands of jewish
cultural objects
which had been assembled by the germans
for example the germans collected torah
rolls
a warehouse full of torah scrolls
uh
tons of jewish ceremonial objects taken
from all the occupied territories it was
an einstein rosenberg a special unit
alfred rosenberg was the
nazi ideologue and was named in his
honor
which had that as their assignment to go
and seize all jewish cultural objects
and
hold them the nazis had various plans
for them these were eventually assembled
in a big warehouse in wiesbaden under
the custody of the united states army
and they in turn turned it over to the
jewish restitution success organization
in which i was the director
now there too our first goal was to try
to
locate the owners
if there was a kiddush plate or
something which had the name this is the
family of motherhood so and so of warsaw
we'd try to find out where the man was
or if it came from a congregation which
still existed we try to send it there
um
we did the same incidentally with the
individual properties of restitution if
the owner showed up late and said well i
didn't file the claim on time or i
didn't was too short but i'm really the
owner i'm the early the heir we worked
out we called an equity procedure of
giving the property back to the real
owners subject to us very modest 10
percent it was service charge for the
expenses and getting it back so here to
our first goal was to restore it to the
rightful owners
but usually you couldn't tell
so the next goal was to try to
distribute them wherever they were
needed for jewish reconstruction the
reconstruction of jewish life
and a separate entity was set up by the
jewish organizations to do that called
jewish cultural reconstruction and
professor salo baron
of columbia university who was a member
of our board of directors
was in charge of that and hannah arndt
was one of the persons who first came to
germany to help guide us with
what to do with these things because i
really had i was a young fella and i i
didn't really know anything about jewish
cultural life in germany and
particularly the religious life
uh so we set up this jewish cultural
reconstruction and we had staff we were
still in nuremberg this is the very
early days
to come in to help us with that hannah
arndt was one and then we brought in
experts from israel there was a
gentleman by the name of narciss another
tsunami who came in from the bizarre
museum in israel to help us with the the
kiddush cups and with the pointers and
with all of the the torah crowns and all
of the objects
and
we also had people restoring them we had
for example a school of scribes working
in paris to restore torah scrolls
and
i learned that a scroll can be repaired
except if the word shaddai god is
injured in which case you cannot if
that's been damaged you cannot restore
that the torah school has to be buried
in israel and following a certain
religious ritual all of which we
followed very precisely
and
i was very insistent on that i said look
i we take the law as laid down by the
rabbinical council and we don't vary
that in any way and that's absolutely
strictly to be observed and it was
and the school of scribes sat in paris
on the control of the jdc and they
repaired those torahs which could be
saved and this rabbinical council would
advise where they were needed new
congregations in israel the big
recipients
congregations in other parts of the
world where there were no they needed
and some we sent as
remembrance scrolls to different uh
different communities throughout the
world
and we did the same with the ceremonial
objects where we could find the owner we
restored them well we couldn't uh we
returned them where it was in damage we
restored them we then distributed
wherever it was needed and at the end we
still had tons
of broken silver
knives forks dishes plates all kinds of
little bits and scraps
and the question is what do we do with
that
and i've been very careful
found a jewish silversmith gold smith
brothers in london
and we said all right we'll send it to
them this cannot be repaired we cannot
trace the owners they are just scraps
nothing can be done with it uh we'll
smelt it down and we will use the
proceeds then for jewish charity
and i thought that was being very clever
and
i then went to the board of directors in
new york where we had our annual
meetings and i reported on the great
care which we had exercised and
disposing of all these things and you
know i was feeling very cocky and very
proud of myself and i said and now we
have received i think it was fifty
thousand dollars or something like that
for these uh silver scraps which we sent
off to the silversmith goldsmith
brothers in london and they smelted them
and they sent us the proceeds and this
is now available for distribution by the
charitable organizations
whereupon the first person to raise his
hand a member of the board of directors
very distinguished
elderly gentleman he is now and was less
elderly than but
still living
isaac lewin who was the chairman of the
argus israel world organization
and he said mr forense
to my ears believe me
you took these holy objects
and you sent them to a crematorium you
know
boy i knew from that question i was
cooked
and i tried to explain as best i could
that
was not really a crematorium it was just
you know our way of trying to carry out
our assignment and realize the
assets to the benefit of those who
survived i don't think he ever really
forgave me for that but we did become
good friends in later years uh but it's
an illustration
of uh
some of the problems you know of uh
dealing with this new area which had
never been done before and we had
paintings which we disposed of and we
had all kinds of things and it was
another facet of the restitution program
what did hannah arendt do
hannah arndt was there for a relatively
short period of time but she
being very cultured and educated knowing
the jewish communities of germany very
well
she was helpful to us in identifying
various ceremonial objects she knew what
period they were from you know where
they might have been from uh where there
had been collections of it
let me tell you another story
of collections
among the
collections were of course many jewish
books prayer books are very kind some
are in quinable i'm not sure exactly
what that is
for the whole jewish books you know and
of great value
the germans also had collected such
books and and i mean german universities
german churches
part of their religious studies and the
nazis had picked that up too so the
previous owners had been germans
uh who had or institutions that had
legitimately acquired those books
and they were quite valuable
one day a jewish rabbi
a chaplain
i think his
name
was bernstein
um
pulled up with an ambulance
to the back of one of these archives and
selected
some of the most valuable jewish books
and filled up the ambulance
and put them on a ship smuggling
immigrants to israel palestine as it was
then known
and
so
these were
books which had belonged
to
legitimate german institutions and had
been lawfully acquired
so it was a case of unlawful
confiscation
and one day i got a call from general
clay
and he said benny you better come up
here we got a problem
and um
he said i have this captain i'm about to
court-martial him for stealing jewish
german property
um
and he said we have a restitution
program here the restoring property to
those from whom it's unlawfully taken
that doesn't mean you can go out and
steal property from the germans and i
think i'm going to have to quote martial
and i said look don't do that for god's
sakes i mean
is that really necessary the jewish
organizations and the you know
mitigating circumstances that he thought
it was jewish property he didn't know i
didn't know
i said i'll get it back he said all
right you go and get it back for me i
said okay i'm going to go to israel i
have to deliver a shipload of
prefabricated houses
i bought from austria with restitution
money i'll get it back give me a list so
he gave me a long list and i know it was
10 12 pages of different books of which
i didn't know nothing
and i go to israel
and i meet with the government officials
there i thought i was in contact finance
ministry mostly and i say look
general clay says i got to make
restitution
and we've got to make restitution this
property where is it
he said it's in mount scopus well let's
go up to mount scopus and get it i got
to bring it back i promise i'm going to
bring it back and they're going to let
this captain off the hook
remember they sent them home they sent
them right home
um
philip bernstein it was
and um
um
i said well it's mount scopus says you
can't go there the arabs are up there
it's between us and the arabs it was the
old city so you can't go up to hebrew
university mount scopus can't get there
so when can i get up there so when the
war's over good i'll tell dr clay so i
go back to berlin and i report to
general clay and i tell them sorry
general they're ready to make
restitution
but uh the arabs are there like you
don't want me to go and send me some
tanks i'll go get it but otherwise i
can't you have to wait till things quiet
down then we'll get restitution and he
accepted that and then of course he left
shortly thereafter mr mccloy came in and
to my knowledge that has never been
settled by way of restitution although
we did have such a problem in the hague
and negotiations with the germans and i
think the templars a a
german society of temples whose land had
been taken in israel they made some kind
of a deal which may have incorporated
some of these books i really don't know
but it was a case of
the jewish organizations being required
to make restitution but they did or not
i really cannot swear
you've been in germany now more than a
year haven't you
what do you mean at the time you said
you were going to
oh yes well of course we stayed in
germany for we expected to stay for one
year 10 years well after being there for
10 years we had four children and i just
didn't want them to be raised in germany
needed my wife and so we decided to
resign
from these organizations and return to
new york but i did remain as adviser to
these organizations for very many years
after that what was life like for you
and your family there
it was a colonials
cloistered existence perhaps you would
ask my wife to explain what it was from
her point of view um we didn't
fraternize
the first german that i led into my
house
after being lived in germany for seven
years was uh
as a guest anyway was professor franz
berm who had walked out of the head of
the german delegation in protest against
the action of his government but i may
tell you about that when we talk about
the hague negotiations but it was a very
colonial type existence the americans
fraternized only with the americans
germans were used as servants it was a
time when cigarettes were the currency
everything was very cheap
it was a comfortable life like the
british living in india
would be comparable
there were some tensions
before the einsatz group and defendants
were executed i received several death
threats
i took
the name off my door
we had death threats later in connection
with the hague negotiations which we may
have a chance to go into
but it was comfortable in the sense we
could travel it's a nice country nothing
wrong with the mountains we could travel
to bavaria we traveled to other parts of
europe we were young
and
but it was not a happy place to be
you always felt beleaguered sort of you
were surrounded by persons that
regarded you as vermin
the years before and suddenly they never
heard of such a thing
so you felt rather entrapped
and besieged in a hostile sea
but nevertheless they were not
unhappy years but we were happy to be
able to leave and we were determined to
leave before the job was really done
did you see black market activity in the
beginning
nobody could live in germany without
seeing black market activity germany was
run on a black market
everything was black market there was
nothing else
outside the black market i mean there
were rations sure i mean you could
choose between bread or beer
but
there was an official black market in
berlin for example which was set up by
mrs clay where
in order to attempt to curb the wild
black mark and cigarette stone they
could bring their stuff to this central
black market it wasn't called that it
was trading trading post or something
and they'd get coupons for so many
pounds of coffee or and then so many
coupons for uh for a camera like a
camera then you could exchange one
against the other uh
and the cigarettes was it was the
currency literally people would work for
you for cigarettes
for cigarette butts
so it was
very grim from that point of view
it helpful in it with black market
helpful or always harmful
well
it's hard to answer that question i did
have a discussion with this dr schwartz
in paris
about that it's interesting that you
should raise it
um
the jews were receiving from the jdc
equivalent of care apostles they were
parcels containing various things that
they needed
sugar coffee clothing
material to mate
and the jdc was sending in
mostly
uh cigarettes because that was the most
negotiable item
and i discussed that with joe schwartz
from the morrow point of view i said
look
uh all the dps are now trading
cigarettes it's illegal it's black
market
um
don't you think you're better off
setting up soup kitchens
rather than just sending in these things
and they're all on their own
which meant they were all engaging in
illegal activities
and he said no he said um
i think that first of all we get much
more bang for our buck this way you know
this was the currency of trade the
cigarettes were cheap and you know you
could buy a lot for it and we need you
know we don't we're short of funds as
they always were
secondly he said
um it's an outlet for their emotions and
they will return to normal life
uh
once they are taken out of this
atmosphere
so that this
my concern was that they would you know
their moral standards would would be
destroyed by engaging in illegal
activities they would lose all respect
for law
and i couldn't persuade him was
the end of it and and in retrospect he
probably was right
um
because
people had in order to survive
legality was rather irrelevant they were
living in a very unlawful world it was
unlawful state
and
they did whatever they had to do in
order to survive
and in that kind of an atmosphere to
come
as i was inclined to do being a lawyer
with
notions of strict legality
was
unrealistic and perhaps unfair
and i was overly concerned about that
anyway the black market didn't time as
the economy improved disappear
and
i'm not sure that it did any big harm
anywhere it exchanged goods a lot of
german goods were exchanged for a lot of
cigarettes
but
another form of restitution perhaps but
i don't think it had any any permanent
significance
did you visit any dp camps during this
year oh yes indeed of course there were
dp camps everywhere and we had some
relatives in dp camps some cousins of my
wife i had no personal relatives of my
own there but some cousins of my wife
were there and
there was also
the conditions were of course very rough
but
not as compared to the concentration
camps but everyone was very eager to
recreate their lives
they were remarrying
any survivor would you know marry
another and raising children as quickly
as they could in
a defiance
that
hitler was not going to succeed
ben what was done to help the
victims with their own injuries
that seems to me to be
perhaps
the most important or next to the most
important
um phase
of dealing with holocaust problems
um
holocaust begins with stopping the
holocaust
wars are holocaust
voice forms of holocaust
the next
phase is to hold accountable those who
brought it on these are the war crimes
trials
the third phase is trying to
restore
what had been destroyed or taken during
the war that's the restitution program
and then the next phase is the victims
what about the victims
people tend to forget
in the drama of the courtroom they think
ah the criminals are punished it's over
that's not over the victims are more
important than the criminals criminals
can be punished or killed that doesn't
make a big difference unless it's a
deterrent to the repetition of the
crimes but what do you do about those
who survived
and this was a problem which was not
addressed by military government except
in the very crudest way of seeking
compensation for time spent in a
concentration camp but it's much more
complicated than that the victims
suffered all kinds of losses
and if you approach the problem legally
then it requires a completely different
and much more expanded approach
and that was the next thing that
happened
if you want me to tell you about that
now i'll tell you how it began
and how it was approached
the notion that the individual survivors
of nazi persecution jewish or non-jewish
should be compensated for their injuries
is an old notion it was quite obvious to
anyone who was concerned with the
subject and people had begun to write
about it in israel in the united states
about compensating victims of personal
injuries
germany was eager
to
re-enter the family of nations
conrad adenauer
was a devout catholic
anti-nazi
who had been saved with the help of
jewish friends
when the nazis had been
trying to drive him out as mayor of
cologne
and
he was very eager in fact to find some
way of reaching out to the jewish
community
he was able to do that through a banker
in london
by the name of noah baru
who established
first contacts
with the german government this is the
post-nazi government
saying let us
try to arrange something
naham goldman was involved very early
no beru was connected to the world
jewish congress nahum goldman was
president of the world jewish congress
which he had created
and a very skillful negotiator and very
diplomatic
person really
and
the first question was are the germans
serious
no one trusted the germans
but the feeling was look
what are the options to let him get away
with it and walk away and
say nothing
uh there was a biblical phrase which was
used you know
they shall not steal you know kill the
victims
and yet steal their property and get
away with it it was the same thing with
compensation that was behind the
restitution programs but compensation is
something else compensation is payment
for individual injuries sustained
and ad now
uh of course he had to clear with his
government he was conservative
cdu conservative democratic union the
socialists were more inclined they
themselves had been nazi victims many of
them
and
so
the first thing was necessary was to
test their sincerity and goldman said
look i want to have a commitment of a
minimum of a billion dollars
maybe it was a billion marks
goldman never knew the difference
between dollars and marks it had to be a
big figure you know it was a billion
that's a lot you know the germans didn't
know what a billion was because they
called it a milliard
it was a thousand million
anyway
uh ad now i was able to give him
assurances that after clearing with his
parliament that he would the negotiation
would be serious
and eventually
the
agreement was reached that we would
enter into negotiations
but the negotiations would have three
parties
one the german government
by that i mean the west german
government the east german government
never answered
um
communications were sent to them this
only began after germany
was restored to its sovereignty
around 1951
and
before then there was no government to
deal with
and
the agreement was reached that
negotiation would be entered into
on neutral territory
no jewish organization wanted to go into
germany i started saying there were
three parties
one hand the german government on the
other hand the state of israel state of
israel at that time was a very new state
um
a lot of enemies the whole arab world
was aligned against it
and they needed someone to represent the
jews not in israel because israel never
purported to speak for jews who were not
in israel and who was to speak for them
most of the jews were not in israel they
had fled
and polish jews russian jews
german jews
and so a third party was necessary and
goldman had the genius to put it
together in what he called the
conference on jewish material claims
against germany
it began as a conference and then kept
the name conference
should have been a committee or
something else but it kept the name and
it consisted of a
collection of the leading jewish
organizations in the world the world
jewish congress american jewish
committee the american joint
distribution committee central british
fund the jews of argentina the the
central the jews of france they all came
together and formed a new york
corporation called the conference on
jewish material claims against germany
and they were going to be the third
negotiating party so that the germans
would be negotiating with all the jews
of the world and the negotiations would
take place at a secret destination
um
in a
neutral
country
to give you some idea of the feel for it
there was a big outcry in the jewish
community
particularly in israel
this is a betrayal of jewish honor
you are selling my mother
you are trying to get money for blood
um
those who do this will be betrayed by
the germans we the only good germans are
dead german we want nothing to do with
them we don't want their lousy money
have nothing to do with them you're a
betrayer of the jewish people if you
dare to sit with them
um begin was the leader of the ergun at
that time they were busily engaged in
smuggling jews into palestine
before that jewish state had been
created
and
they felt
very violent about that
to such an extent that they did send
a bomb
in a grosser brookhouse the german
encyclopedia addressed adnaw which was
intercepted by the police in munich and
when they opened this big encyclopedia
the bomb exploded they killed two
policemen
they
had sent
a
letter bomb
to the head of the german delegation
well let me to give you some little
closer feel of what this is like
um
i
the negotiating the preparations for
this meeting took place
at the grosner house in london for about
a week before we were going to go in and
we were then trying to prepare the
opening statements i was there as
council
to
the claims conference
and because i was the director of the
jrso i knew about restitution i knew
what had happened more or less and uh so
i was you know an expert so-called in
the field there were other experts who
were much more expert than i uh in the
fields of reparations and so on i think
of nahemia robinson his brother jacob
robinson these were really very learned
international lawyers coming out of
lithuania
but we had a crew was working in the
grosner house in london
trying to prepare the opening statements
and decide on what theory and what are
we asking for and how do you justify it
since my wife and i had parachuted out
of a plane over berlin some recent time
before i was not eager to fly to
wherever the
meeting place was supposed to be and it
was rumored that it was to be in
brussels
so i said look
tell me you know i'll get there by train
and
i was told when we left the grove in the
house
you'll be given an envelope follow the
don't open it until you get into the
taxi and when you get there
then you open it and follow the
instructions
we were under the security guard of the
israeli secret service
and
i opened it up and it said proceed to
hook from holland
i went to hope von holland i said
strange way to go to brussels but
i figured as much at you know some other
destination
and there i was checked out the
customs i came in they looked at my
passport and looked me over and mr
friends yes just a moment and then they
had some
man come out of the back room and come
with me and i sat in a big black buick
and off we drove into the night
and after dave i began to break i said
the man i said excuse me i said
can you tell me who are you and where
are you taking me oh he said i'm the
dutch secret police he said and i'm
taking you to a meeting site okay fine
the door was breaking we pull into what
looks to me like an old castle it was
castelo vasana the town of asana
and
it seemed to me i see
ss men with police dogs there
and moy my heart just sunk into my
stomach the insects group and defendants
had been executed not long before and i
thought i'd walk into a trap of there
was a nazi underground as well
but as i looked a little more closely
what i first blush thought were ss
were the dutch police they wear the same
type uniform black uniform without the
death head and without the silver stripe
on the pants and i noticed that very
quickly and i realized it was not a trap
but i came in i checked in at the at the
desk of this
castle had been converted to a hotel
first class hotel
and i was assigned a room
but i was told open no drawers
open no doors as the policeman stationed
on every floor
and if there's anything suspicious don't
touch anything immediately alert the
policeman on every floor
and the german delegation came in
headed by professor franz berm and
otto custer
uh
whom i had mentioned
and
berm received an envelope a letter a
letter bomb envelope a little bomb
envelope is an ordinary looking envelope
which has a paper inside and on the
bottom of it it's there's black powder
and a detonator so when you pull it out
the detonator explodes the powder and
will kill anybody who has it in his hand
or anybody nearby that was intercepted
by the dutch police
and the israeli police i think it was
and uh we were told you know
be careful because we knew that a member
of the stern gang uh andy ergon
had
entered brussels looking for us and was
already in holland they had been
tracking him
um
so it was filled with a lot of
apprehension there was one a plane uh
coming in
uh from israel with two israeli
delegates
crashed over frankfurt uh crash-landed
and killed everybody on the plane we
don't know that there was any connection
we did not have any advance notice of
that and i don't know to this day it may
have been just an unfortunate
coincidence but it was i hope it was but
it was an area of high tension when
goldman appeared in israel knesset was
stoned when they debated this there were
people marching the streets uh
against it threatening to kill him
trying to kill anybody who was connected
with the negotiations
so that was the way we began
uh and there what we're trying to do
was to create
a sense of justice for the injuries the
germans coined the term veda gudmahn
which literally means make good again
but you can't make good again this kind
of injury all you can do is try to
ameliorate it to some extent
and that i felt and the others who were
connected with it was a moral obligation
as well as a legal obligation if you
injure someone
you owe them the duty of trying to make
recompense as best you can and to heal
them as best you can and that problem
continues to this day so the japanese
use of comfort women and so on other
parts of the world it's a continuing
problem but at that time it was new uh
no one had ever done this before no one
had ever sat down after a war to provide
individual compensation to the victims
of not only that war but of the
persecutions related to it
and
to work out the principles and to set up
the machinery and to put it into
legislative form so that it'll be passed
by a parliament and be enforced by a
whole series of judicial instruments and
courts and agencies on an enormous scale
i mean millions of claims jews and
non-jews
this was not strictly a jewish program
but no one should mistake that the jews
were the primary targets and perhaps the
worst certainly the worst targets
although the gypsies were close behind
of of the nazi extermination programs
but there were very many other victims
including german victims
and it would be a mistake to disregard
them and we didn't disregard them in in
trying to work out the compensation laws
to indemnify them for their injuries we
never made a distinction between jews
and non-jews they all had equal rights
under the law
then what happened
well
let me give you some idea of the legal
principles involved
first
what do you ask for
we had global sums in mind when we
negotiated the hag and there were global
sums agreed upon
three billion marks was to go to israel
to help cover some of the costs that
they had incurred in absorbing the
immigrants
of nazi persecution trying to
rehabilitate them it was a global sum
which at that time
was vital for the salvation of israel
germany had no money
um
germany was devastated
how do you pay it it was repaid over a
period of 10 to 12 years the first
payments were oil shipments israel was
at war
uh what were their primary needs
the claims conference was to get 500
million dollars for uh
compensation to the jews uh outside of
israel
to help ameliorate them that was for
organizational assistance then we had
from these payments incidentally
the israeli railroads were built
uh the israel electrical system was
built in germany if anybody's been in
israel they know the taxi cabs are all
made by
mercedes
this was a great help
and it was rather ironic
that the state which had set out to
destroy the jews was so helpful in fact
in
enabling the
only jewish state
to survive and it was so
um and people like to forget it and and
say no but it's an unfair thing to do
um
now then what do you do for the
individual how do you measure
well we decided very early on we were
not going to ask anything for loss of
life you don't take six million dollars
or six billion dollars for the loss of
six million lives
but you do
take the ordinary principles of law
if a child lost his father who was his
provider
and the provider
was a high income middle income or
low-income person he'd be entitled to
compensation based upon that but he had
to prove
that he had a father that his father was
murdered by the nazis that the father
had a certain income that a certain
portion of that income would have been
used for that child that it would have
been for that child for a certain number
of years that the german government
should pay for it that they should pay
for it for a limited or permanent period
of time they should pay in whole or in
pot or percentage how much can they
afford to pay the lie stone phase kite
the ability to pay was
the theme song we have to have
within our ability we have other
obligations to pay the hold of the bonds
so working out all of these principles
of law how to measure the compensation
like an insurance company
all of these things were worked out and
six months of detailed acrimonious
negotiation to produce finally the
german bundes and sheila kung's gazettes
the law for the compensation of nazi
victims
next weekend on sunday november 29th
we'll hear part three of this interview
with benjamin ferenz in the third part
mr ferenz discusses the aftermath of the
war crimes trials and how the jewish
community fought to retrieve lost
property through the claims conference
which was established in 1951 that
sunday november 29th at 8 50 a.m eastern
on c-span 3's american history tv on our
schedule and to keep up with the latest
history news
in november 1945 war crimes trials began
in nuremberg germany for major nazi
figures a subsequent trial called the
einsatzgruppen case involved 24 nazi ss
defendants accused of killing more than
a million people
for the 70th anniversary of the
nuremberg trials c-span's american
history tv is airing an oral history
interview with benjamin franz former
united states chief prosecutor in the
insets group in case mr forense was born
in transylvania to a jewish family and
immigrated to america when he was an
infant he enlisted in the us army after
earning his law degree and later was
assigned to set up a war crimes branch
to investigate nazi atrocities
next in part three of his interview he
discusses the aftermath of the war
crimes trials and how the jewish
community fought to retrieve lost
property through the claims conference
which was established in nineteen fifty
one the mission of the conference still
active today is to secure in its words a
small measure of justice for jewish
victims of nazi persecution
this is the last portion of the
three-part interview it was conducted by
the united states holocaust memorial
museum in washington dc
it's about an hour
ben can we talk about what sort of
problems you had in the claims with the
claims conference
uh and in terms of
was it like what happened with
restitution well the claims conference
was the umbrella organization
acting
as the voice of the
jewish community
naham goldman had obtained authorization
in fact to speak for israel so we had
one voice speaking for the jewish
community which was important
the first thing i did was i set up an
office in bonn to serve as a lobby
to watch the germans and see that they
carried out the program
nahum goldman was very effective every
time he came to bond which was quite
regular he would meet with all the heads
of the political different political
parties in order to assure their support
the man that i sent to be in charge of
the office in bonn was a man who had
worked with us in nuremberg a former
jewish german berlin lawyer by the name
of herbert schernfeld who was a bachelor
and a very charming man
and he said what shall i do in bonn i
took him out of he was head of the jrs
or stuttgart office and i said you make
friends all you have to do is make
friends and i gave him a big american
car which cost nothing because i got it
from the army we had free gasoline and
free logistics support
and
he i said i want to know what the
germans are thinking before they think
it
and he was the man for that he knew all
the secretaries he knew all the people
in bonn he was very popular
and
the problem was to persuade the germans
to make the size of payments in the
category of payment that we wanted and
the germans didn't want to they had
their own financial problems the finance
minister said look this will bankrupt
germany we can't accept these unlimited
liabilities
at one time we even talked about
requiring every german to pay one mark a
week or a month
toward a fund so that they would realize
that they were paying
compensation for what had happened in
their name
but that
was not
dealt with very seriously and would not
have been feasible
and so the germans undertook with great
hesitation different categories of
payments the german public was
completely unaware
they felt no pain whatsoever as a result
of these programs germany prospered
and
the losses were much greater than anyone
had anticipated we had made our
appraisals beforehand and estimated it
would be 6 billion marks or 9 billion
marks and the germans said oh no it's
going to be 12 billion marks and we
can't afford that and
by the time this program is over
it will cost the germans well over a
hundred billion marks they've already
passed a hundred billion mark figure
that in today's dollars is seven
hundred
no it's seven seventy cents a market a
hundred billion marks would be about
seventy billion dollars is what it will
cost
the west german government now the free
united german government to meet these
claims there were literally millions of
claims filed i think it was three or
four million claims jews and non-jews
alike don't forget that these are not
only jewish claims
and
the uh
response we had the claims had to be
proved in every case the individual
claimant had to prove that he was
injured as a result direct consequence
of nazi action if he could prove that he
was permanently disabled
he would get a lifelong pension
and they're paid now i don't know how
many are still alive but the last time i
looked at the count a few years ago
perhaps there were over a hundred
thousand
nazi victim survivors jewish nazi victim
survivors who are getting lifelong
pensions from the west german government
most of these people are in israel the
demarcus is very valuable currency the
israel currency would fluctuate
this was a lifesaver for them
and
in order for them to get recognition
however they had to persuade the german
doctors
that
the disability was caused by the
persecution that was not easy because
for years they denied that there could
be any mental
uh disability
caused
if it did not appear immediately on
liberation
many people and anybody who was in the
business who knew the people knew it was
so
managed to hold themselves together
for many years and then maybe five ten
twenty years later suddenly they would
break down
and uh by that time the filing deadlines
had all expired they may have been
recognized for a small disability they
had to prove that you know their
grandfather had not had a nervous
breakdown at some point and the german
doctors were hostile
i must say they were hostile
and the german agencies we had to deal
with this were very often hostile
depended upon the area berlin for
example was known to be more liberal
there was a man in charge there by the
name of lipschitz who was very kind and
tried to be fair in bavaria we had
nothing but troubles tough fighting all
along the way
um
and uh
this required legal services of all
kinds to help the claimants clements
themselves never really understood uh
they say it's veda goodman why didn't
they get more
what they got seemed to them
to be poultry and it was in many
respects um
and
they couldn't understand
that every case was different
they said my sister got the same well my
friend
there was exactly the thing why did they
get more than i did well there was
always a reason sometimes it wasn't a
good reason but to have them understand
that was very difficult so this entire
program which expanded as we went along
it was originally intended to be over by
10 years i knew it would never be over
by 10 years
the laws had to be modified they were
expanded finally the germans were
getting tired of that and they called it
a schliss gazette it's the final law
well after they got through with the
schloss gazettes it wasn't screws they
had to come with a hardship fund and
then after the hatchet fund they came
with another hardship fund because every
time you started to implement the
program you discovered the losses were
much greater than you anticipated than
any of us anticipated and since germany
was prospering
and many of these
payments were linked to their own civil
service
so that when their own civil servants
got a promote a raise in their pensions
the jewish nazi victims got not the same
amount they never got the same amount
but something lesser but they also got
some raise and so over the years these
payments were very significant and as i
look back upon it in retrospect the
program is still going on
but it should be over within the next 10
20 years as the last victims die off as
i look back upon it it was a unique
historical achievement
and it was a great achievement it was a
great achievement from a moral point of
view the awareness and recognition that
the wrongdoer has an obligation to his
victim to try to help them from a legal
point of view
developing the principles of
compensation the principles of law which
should bind people under similar
circumstances which i hope are never
repeated but which i fear are being
repeated
so when you look at it as i look back
upon it
i think it was a a very great thing
uh it was done in the name of all of the
jewish organizations on behalf of the
nazi survivors
it was inadequate
to make good again any of their
suffering
but at least it was a gesture that
somebody cared and they had not been
forgotten
jews and non-jews made claims
yes
to the to the claims conference no the
claims conference didn't handle claims
except the hardship fund claims which
came later but the claims had to be
submitted to a german agency and if you
were not satisfied with that you had
again go through the german judicial
system up to the german supreme court
and german constitutional court and the
united restitution organization which
was another organization that i was
involved when it was set up
and i was the director of that um
we took many cases to the german supreme
court and had to take up the
constitutional court to assert our
rights sometimes we won sometimes we
didn't
are there any particular stories
involved in these claims that you might
want to
talk about well i think the
fundamental story
which uh
disturbed me for many years was the
german failure to recognize
uh the s spate shot the late claims this
these ailments which would appear only
years later
several years later particularly mental
helmets but it's not only mental people
would suddenly get heart trouble get
other things and the germans refused to
recognize that although medical science
was beginning to recognize that people
had been subjected to trauma might have
this uh
syndrome late
syndrome which i may be a victim of
myself
but they began to recognize that when
the german troops began coming home from
the soviet union
suddenly they realized
that these soldiers who had been
subjected to the most difficult
circumstances while in soviet captivity
uh were suffering from mental ailments
of various kinds and other physical
ailments and they began to compensate
them incidentally
the payments made to german ss officers
their pension payments were vastly
higher than any amounts
given to jewish survivors although they
were important to the jewish survivors
we don't want to exaggerate their
importance in relationship to germany's
overall budget and how much they spent
on their own their widows of their own
fallen ss heroes as they consider them
and ss officers
so
this whole category of of mental
ailments
uh was badly treated by the germans very
badly treated for very many years and
many people died before they could get
any compensation and had to be reversed
by the courts
and
some
court decisions were outrageous
outrageously unfair to the claimants
so germany felt much more obligation to
the perpetrators oh yes well they didn't
call them perpetrators to their own
fallen heroes you know
but uh
that was a different category this was
something imposed upon them outside
their normal judicial framework and they
always regarded as such they always said
this is bizundera
you know
legislation this was something special
and the ordinary principles of law
didn't apply to these payments this was
an argument they frequently made saying
look we're doing you a favor uh get off
our back
uh don't come to us with legal
principles which apply to us germans
when we have our own german law you know
this is a special law and it's limited
and there are limits to what we can pay
there was some truth in it but
and it's more than other governments
have done
but this were the problems of those on
the ground trying to get as much as we
could for the victims
and and we did that did you have help
from jewish organizations
well this was all done in the name of
the jewish organizations uh fortunately
for them uh for uh for everybody i guess
they didn't have to put any money into
this
because uh we generated all the money on
the ground uh from the first payment
that supported all the meetings and all
the the salaries and uh everything else
i also managed to get tax exemptions
from germany for uh many of these
expenditures
and
the organizations themselves i mean they
welcomed uh germany paying of course i'm
always prepared to go to washington with
a delegation and say pay more
particularly if it got in the new york
times or even in the jewish week or a
jewish telegraphic agency
but
in terms of making a sacrifice
it's fortunate for the victims that
their jewish organization were not
called upon to make sacrifices
can you talk about the establishment of
the united restitution organization
yes
um the it was very obvious from the very
beginning
that uh
if the nazi victims were to assert their
claims effectively
pursuant to the german laws or the
military government laws they would need
legal help there was no member of the
german bar who was not a nazi
it was a requirement if you were not a
nazi you couldn't be admitted to the bar
the prospect of
nazi victims jewish nazi victims going
to german lawyers
and paying them
in an effort to get compensation the
nature which was highly uncertain and
the value of which was highly uncertain
was not something that they would do if
there were no agency to assist them with
their claims the whole legislative
programs that we worked out would be
meaningless
and so
we set up by we again i mean i was the
director
the jdc was the leading body there had
been a small organization of german
jewish lawyers
uh who had fled from germany and set
themselves up in england and they were
handling some restitution claims for the
return of property they were being
supported by the jdc and the central
british fund i think the jewish agency
very small payments and a very small
program
and when i set up the program i
incorporated them they were called the
united restitution office i call it the
united restitution organization to
maintain the the continuity their
chairman was a very fine gentleman by
the name of norman bentwich professor
norman bandwich distinguished englishman
dear friend
outstanding citizen
and
then i expanded it with money which the
germans had paid
i
borrowed from the claims conference a
few million dollars
and expanded that operation the claims
government got the money from the
germans i repaid it to the claims
conference later
and expanded the organization so that
when i left germany in 1956
i had a staff of 250 german lawyers
1200 people
offices in 19 different countries
offices in every major city in germany
in israel wherever there were large
concentrations of jews who needed help
with their claims
the united restitution office set up an
office
in israel we had one in tel aviv and
haifa and jerusalem
in the united states we had an office on
the west coast in los angeles which
still exists in new york which still
exists in philadelphia we had offices in
baltimore
we had offices in stockholm which we
closed in latin america in johannesburg
we had offices all around the world
and these officers were there
to give assistance
to claimants with no down payment a
small contingent fee
which enabled the organization to
maintain itself
um funneling hundreds of thousands of
claims
through
to the german agencies and in germany we
had offices in frankfurt in berlin and
stuttgart and munich and cologne and
mannheim and all around the place
wherever there were
german agencies dealing with these
claims we set up an office uh with
lawyers of our own choice
always the heads of offices were always
jewish lawyers
we didn't rely on german lawyers except
as you know subsidiary staff and then we
screened them
so this was a very big operation largely
unheard of
worked very well i must say and i just i
set it up in 19
oh i guess it was around 1951
and i resigned from that in 19
i guess it was 92 or 3 after about 40
years in all that time
we dealt with hundreds of millions of
dollars and thousands and thousands of
claims
there was never a trace of any scandal
of any kind not a single client was able
to demonstrate a few did complain they
didn't get enough but malpractice we had
no malpractice insurance and we never
had any
indication of anything other than a
clean and upright uh
organization
which did not satisfy all the clients
most of them felt they didn't get enough
you know and but some of them did i mean
they appreciated it and
it was also a very unique type of
operation it was no doubt the biggest
legal aid society that ever existed
and
now they're down to
maybe a hundred people altogether the
headquarters are still in frankfurt
uh
seoul kagan who's my original deputy
from 48 is now chairman of the board i
had resigned as chairman of the board as
well
and
it still carries on and it tries to help
as best it can
are there any particular aspects of that
you want to go you go into
in the establishment of the
this large legal aid society
that you think are important
uh
well the usual uh
bureaucratic problems there was
initially
some
conflict i would say a conflict is
perhaps too strong
some difference in emphasis on the
german jews and the non-german jews
for a while the office in israel was
divided the german jews had their type
of claim and the non-german jews polish
jews primarily had their type of claim
and they tried to run them as separate
departments i refused that and they had
the same in new york they were different
floors of a building i said no it's one
organization where all nazi victims
they're all jews they'll be treated all
the same no segregation whatsoever and
that the dichotomy didn't last long
then what happened to that original debt
the million marks that i borrowed from
occupation funds on authorization of
general clay
well
as i told you i had signed a document
promising to repay it out of restitution
monies when the monies came in which
seemed like a
fair enough arrangement to avoid having
to get consent from the russians and the
british and the french
when the money was gone
mr clay was also gone general clay was
also gone and mr mccloy was in his place
so i went to see high commissioner john
mccloy
and i explained to him being an honest
man
that i had borrowed this million marks
against occupation funds
and that i promised to repay but i said
look the money is just beginning to come
in
there are other priorities i'm trying to
move the dps out of the camps
in germany
into israel and in order to do that i
need the money to buy prefabricated
homes which can be shipped from at that
time everything was under strict control
export import controls
and uh i said i i need the funds to buy
these prefabricated houses in israel and
in austria to ship them to israel
otherwise uh we know we're going to have
the camps blocked and then all the rest
so he said all right all right
i'll you know i need some more money he
said how much more do you need i said uh
a million marks he said can i do that
legally i said i happen to have a memo
here says you can he said okay go ahead
and so i borrowed another million marks
and
to make a long story short when that
million marks was gone it didn't take
too long
i came back to him again and i said look
i
i know that i know i
promise to repay and that money is
coming in but there are other priorities
you know
you shouldn't give priority to repay
occupation funds
there are these other needs and
i need another million marks i'll pay
him back later he said all right okay so
i signed the third time
i had accumulated three million marks
then one day
my time came
mr mccloy in his infinite wisdom of
folly
granted clemency to a lot of convicted
war criminals
including my einstein's group and boys
including alfred krupp who had been
sentenced to seven years in prison as
well as forfeiture of all of his
billions in assets
i went to see mr mccloy
i said mr mccloy
i know that i have promised to pay
the debt is now three million marks
if you insist upon repaying it i will
repay it
but
you have just
given a convicted war criminal three
billion marks in assets
and i don't think it's fair to ask the
victims to pay the expenses of
recovering a small portion of what was
stolen from them
he said what do you want me to do i said
i want you to cancel the debt
he said can i do it legally i said i
have a memo here says you can he said
the debt is cancelled
that's something about mr mccloy the
jewish organization don't know some of
them do because i reported on it of
course
but it's not generally known mccloy was
a great friend to the jews
in the whole restitution program he was
very very helpful in persuading conrad
adenauer and the german government
to
be supportive of jewish claims at a time
when germany was totally dependent
financially and militarily upon the
united states
and uh mr mccloy as former assistant
secretary of war and high commissioner
of germany when he suggested the german
leaders
whether it be adenauer or whether it be
uh some of the others
that they would be in their interest
to
be more forthcoming
in the dealing of jewish claims
they listened
and one of his speeches he said this
would be the test
of germany's morality and their
readiness to be rejoined with the family
of nations what they did for the nazi
victims
so i think that
mr mccloy
deserves recognition for what he did for
the jews as well as
less criticism for his failure to bomb
the rail lines of auschwitz
which he thought would not help the jews
would kill them more likely than not
uh and for his judgment on that which he
was not alone in he was backed by ben
roseman who was roosevelt's advice
jewish adviser at the time
and uh i think that mccloy has gotten a
bum rap
for some of his actions as misguided as
they were and as detrimental as they
were in fact undermining the message of
nuremberg
outside of the um the cases that you've
been talking about
were there cases
outside of your normal purview
like the
catholic women
yes there were several there were two
major ones come to mind there were
others
one is these catholic women who are
victims of medical experiments the other
slave laborers which we may want to
spend another minute with
the
catholic women story
is fairly simple
the germans in the ravensbruck
concentration camp used young catholic
women that
they didn't just select them because
they were catholics but that happened to
be that they were catholics and used
them for a variety of rather atrocious
medical experiments such as cutting them
open and throwing sand and glass into
their wounds to see how they would heal
and how long it would take them before
they died
these were experiments designed to
simulate the conditions which german
soldiers might face in various traumatic
situations
and
germany
refused to pay them anything because
there were no diplomatic relations
between west germany and the polish
government
and
one of the defects in the german
compensation laws was that they excluded
political persecutes and they excluded
anybody from an uh communist country
um
well it was a lady by the name of
caroline faraday who had been very close
to a french resistance group she was
devout catholic as well
and she came to see me one day
and
she said that
she heard that i had been so helpful i
was then practicing law in new york
to come back
and helping the jews why couldn't i do
something for the catholics
and she explained that
she had gone to norman cousins
who was then the editor of the saturday
review
norman cousins some years before had
started an action
to
help what was called the hiroshima
maidens the women of hiroshima who had
been injured by american
blast atomic weapons and who had been
disfigured and who were brought to new
york where they were treated by dr
hitsek a jewish doctor at mount sinai
hospital and given all kinds of plastic
surgery and restored as far as possible
as a gesture of goodwill the american
public to the japanese that had been a
very successful program in terms of
generating goodwill and showing human
compassion regardless of who the victims
are
and
so he was well known for that he was
himself a world federalist later
president of the world federalist
association and he had an important
influence on my world thinking as well
and uh anyway caroline faraday had gone
to see him and they said look there's no
legal basis for the claims you know it's
different it's a voluntary action
somehow she'd found my name and come to
see me
and i agreed to help them
and
we set up a little committee norman was
chairman and we
brought in some publicist somebody from
life magazine
and
i approached the german government and i
threw the ambassador in washington and
he said we can't pay as you know there's
no provision in the law for it and we
have no diplomatic relations with poland
we're sorry they have no claims
i said had nothing to do with the law
you injured these people
you own
and you're going to pay them
we can't no basis or we'll find a basis
so we arranged a high-pressure publicity
campaign
pan am lent us an airplane
and we filled it up with these women
from warsaw
polish young polish women
we brought them to the united states
i drafted speeches norman drafted
speeches cardinal spellman greeted them
on the steps of saint patrick's
cathedral the jester which was women of
poland we greet you the germans are not
paying you
how can they do such a terrible thing
after all look what they did to you then
we took him to the senate and we took
him to the congress and every senator
who had a polish voter came out he made
a speech on the floor and he began
saying look what they did these germans
you know and they refused to pay them
you know and they used
legal technicalities and so on
and i was on the phone every day with
the german ambassador have you had
enough
and uh finally he said i have had enough
and he said i'm sending a cable to bonn
that this is not a legal matter it's
political matter and they better settle
with these women
and
i proceeded then to bond and the cabinet
was taking this up as a very special
measure outside the law
and the cabinet by that time was very
very annoyed with me
because
i was i had offices in germany had all
this important i knew what they were
thinking what they were doing
and
the word that i got from the middle of
the cabinet meeting
was that they're ready to pay but not to
pay to you
because
they think you're a communist agent
and you're just there to embarrass the
german government
i said to whom are they willing to pay i
don't care whom they pay they got to pay
the girls
i said well
they don't know but they're not going to
pay yes how about the red cross they
said oh yes the red cross they would pay
to the international committee the red
cross i said fine just have them pass a
resolution they'll make payment to the
international committee the red cross i
will be in geneva and i will take it up
with the red cross and they did so off i
went to geneva and i met there was a
mission manual whose name was
m-o-m-u-n-o-i-r
the international committee of the red
cross and i explained the situation
the germans were willing to pay but they
would only pay through the red cross
and
would the red cross be willing to accept
this as an obligation
the red cross was much smarter than i
was
i was ready to settle this with the
germans for i don't remember i think
five million dollars or something like
that too because we only had a
list that time of maybe a hundred girls
all together and what comparison what
the jews were getting five thousand
marks ahead the symbolic payment
the red cross said no we can't accept uh
uh limited liability we can't accept the
closed-ended deal we will accept the
proposition that they will pay we will
certify that they were victims of
medical experiments we will classify
them prosecutor abc depending upon the
gravity of the offense they will set the
amount of compensation 5 000 marks 10
000 marks 25 000 marks and
we will then certify it and they'll pay
all the expenses of course and we will
do it fine i went back to bond you got a
deal
bang and we made the deal
special cabinet resolution the nice end
of the story which delights me
proves that i was a total fool to try to
wreck to excel i would have been willing
to accept a settlement for five million
dollars
by the time
they got through paying that program
it must have cost them 50 times that
much
um i would go past somebody of mine in
the finance ministry and say how many
claimants do you have now we only know
about a hundred a thousand twelve
hundred fifteen hundred they came from
czechoslovakia from poland from austria
from hungary all the medical experiment
victims came and the red cross said that
was the deal and they kept on approving
them and they kept on getting paid and
the minimum payment i'd figured out i
arranged that the payment would be made
in swiss francs as well so they didn't
get worthless zlati and the people could
go abroad in order to get medical
treatment no way they could spend their
money abroad and the payment the minimum
payment i think was what a college
professor in poland would have earned in
two years time so it was a great thing
for these uh polish women and the one of
my most touching moments in my whole
experience this business was a group of
them waiting
uh at the airport in poland to greet me
when i came as a guest to the polish
government to ex you know express their
appreciation for the effort
so that was uh
one of the categories of
claims outside of the normal
range and there were many others the
slave labor claims
are dealt with in detail in my book less
than slaves which unfortunately is out
of print now i hope that harvard
university would be induced by the
holocaust memorial museum to print a
paperback again of that book which has
many useful lessons it's been translated
into german it's been translated into
japanese it's been the basis of a good
german television show
and i would hope that something could be
done
but
there are many others if you shake my
memory a little bit of
another one comes to mind as we talk and
that's
payments
for
the rabbis
i see you raise your eyebrows you never
heard of that nobody ever heard of it
but we asserted a claim during the hague
negotiations
for
payment to all the officials of the
jewish congregations as i indicated
jewish congregations were state
organizations they were entities of the
state and if a school teacher in an
elementary school
lost his job
or stayed long enough he got a pension
if he was a teacher in a hebrew school
he should have been entitled to the same
pension but the germans said no no no we
can't do that because
we don't know who would have been
entitled to a pension how should we know
now all these schools were closed in
1933
and whether the rabbi or the uh sherhat
the root or or the mural or the the
ritual you know all the people who are
involved in jewish congregation and
religious life whether they would be out
of financial we can't know that
so i counted i said look let's make a
global settlement for
i think it was 30 million marks i asked
for at the time and then we'll
distribute oh no we can't do that
uh i said all right we'll make another
deal
we will set up an advisory committee
to check the claims first
and only when we check it and say that
it's okay we pass it on to you then you
can check it again if you like and we
will only
approve those cases where we think the
man would have been entitled to a
pension they bought that
much to my relief much to their regret
because we then set up a small advisory
committee a former german jews mostly i
was the chairman of that committee and
we received thousands and thousands of
applications
of people
who
would have been qualified or felt they
would have been qualified for a pension
from these jewish congregations and we
approved those cases and we passed them
on
to the germans and the germans paid it
was not under the finance ministry but
under their social ministry that's where
they
the ministry which deals with this type
of problem
and i say partly to our shame
there are many cases where we turn down
the claim and they could appeal to the
germans and the germans approved it
so that although we were correct
in our determination of eligibility
there were cases where the germans felt
well
we had turned it down but man would have
been entitled for example typical type
of case would be
a rabbi left germany fled 1935 was able
to get out
somebody else took his position
um
he stayed till 1938 at 37 they closed it
down he worked for two years
was he a career
employee of the congregation so that he
would have been entitled to a pension or
was he only a temper employee
some of the members of my advisory board
said no no he should never have those
circumstances never expected a pension
it was only a temporary thing
i always voted in favor of the claimant
where the matter was in doubt if it was
a thai vote i think we were five it was
two and two i always cast in favor of
the the uh claimant um but many cases we
turned down and the germans said yes
we'll pay him
so it's an example of jews being overly
cautious and germans being a bit more
generous and a completely different
category of case outside the normal
range of the law and of course it costs
the germans very much more than we had
we had originally anticipated at the
beginning
had you met the the
uh polish women prior to that visit to
poland uh no i had not
they had been in the states
and they had been paraded around but i
had not met them individually you know
they had uh
they came then to this airport to greet
me and then we were supposed to go to a
ballet and they i didn't want to leave
them was pouring rain and they'd stay
there with their flowers and they were
all wilted and i said to my host look i
don't want to leave this when they said
no they're all coming and we all went
off to the ballet but they weren't all
there but they came later and visited
and expressed their appreciation and so
it was very very touching experience and
i told them that all i wanted to do in
in poland really was to visit auschwitz
which i'd never seen
and so they gave me a guide and for a
week he took me every place i wanted to
go
and it was very interesting to visit and
they were pleased to have me there
ben can you talk a little bit about the
attitude of the german industrialists
when you started making claims
for slave labor
the german industrialists
had a
rather
unique attitude
they began
by denying
that it ever happened
the attitude was what we employed
concentration camp inmates
next
they denied that they were in any way
responsible or connected with it
ah perhaps they were assigned to us
by the ss
could have been
but the conditions were really very good
so they denied the conditions
then when you pointed out the conditions
were really very terrible ah well we
were not responsible for that we did the
best we could under difficult
circumstances and then the ultimate
payoff was well
you know if it hadn't been for us
they would have gone directly into the
gas chamber
so by our providing work we saved their
lives why are they complaining to us
they owe us
that essentially in summary was the
attitude of all of the industrialists
without exception
despite all of the denials since that
time which have appeared on television
and on radio shows and on all kinds of
other shows that was the universal
response of all of them without
exception
now
i had a little incident
my knowledge of what had happened came
largely from the nuremberg trials
against ig farben which built auschwitz
against krupp
big user of slave labor against flick
who was a big industrialist who had many
companies using slave labor armaments
firms and everything else
automobile companies
and
in nuremberg we had collected the
documentary evidence of this
and the documentary evidence showed what
the truth was
how many people they employed where they
employed them what the conditions were
how much they paid the ss for the
laborers it was a few few fenneys
and
what they had to do in order to qualify
to receive inmates
and
they showed very clearly to me
that you had to have good connections to
the ss you had to be engaged in the
industry which they considered important
you had to be sure to provide security
either by sending your own people to be
trained as ss guards by the ss to put
uh barbed wire all around the particular
plant wherever they're working post
proper security guards and other
security measures um to uh
you know be able to maintain them on a
level which was tolerable to the ss
which means minimum consumption maximum
production failure to do that is
equivalent to being shot dead or treated
as a saboteur
so they had to comply with all that
before they could even be considered
uh for getting labor i'm not talking
about right after the beginning of the
war so where they're rubble people were
seized on the streets and put to work on
rubble i'm talking about regular forced
slave laborers
and i had all the documentary proof
including
the decrees from albert spare who is the
minister responsible for the armaments
industry and for the allocation of labor
and the industrialist with whom i had
met [ __ ] farm and group aeg siemens
telefunken uh
[Music]
all of them took the other line so i
went when crook came out of spandau
prison after 20 years now spend our
prisons in berlin it's an old big it
doesn't exist anymore they ripped it
down when hess was the last prisoner who
died there um
but there's this big fortress of a
prison for these few nuremberg
defendants and spirit spends 20 years
there and every
three months they rotate them the
russians the french the british the
americans and the russians were not
kindly disposed to any of those
prisoners
um
he came out and i arranged to meet him
at the airport in frankfurt secretly
and it was not easy for me to shake
hands with albert spear
but he'd spent 20 years
and in the interim he had written
several books
about his memoirs and in those books and
at nuremberg as well
he had indicated remorse for what had
happened and was prepared to assume
responsibility to a certain extent for
having been involved in supporting
hitler's programs knowing very well
what was happening to the jews and other
forced laborers and there were other
forced laborers as well
so i asked him i said look
i have a question i've come to see you
with a question
i have all your documents your decrees
i have the requisitions i have the
reports from the concentration camp
commanders i have reports from the ss
people who are responsible for the
allocation of labor and they all tell me
one thing and one thing consistently and
only that
all of these industrialists were
fighting to get these inmates and that
the conditions were equivalent to death
that they could only survive a given
number of time
of months in that kind of labor and that
this was known to all of them and yet
they all deny it
how do you explain that
and he said they're lying
and i said can i quote you and he said
yes you may
and i wrote the story in the book less
than slaves and i sent him the draft of
the manuscript beforehand i said mr
krupp is this a correct statement if so
please inform me if it's wrong please
correct it and he wrote on the margin
ein for standing agreed he changed
nothing
so
that was an interesting thing and you
know
when some of these fine industrialists
um representatives of mr krupp
and the others were asked about this
later after we made these paltry
settlements with them which i described
in the book
oh everything was fine you know we had a
moral obligation you know we felt and so
on
but
in truth they paid as little as they
could get away with
they didn't pay
a penny more than they had to
and the real
payoff in in revealing their true
attitude is in what they did for the
non-jews in connection with the ig
farben settlement
at a certain point in the negotiations
the question of non-jews came up
gentleman by the name of langbang had
been a head of a group of auschwitz
non-jewish survivors and he had been
agitating for uh compensation for them
too and the ig farm people said look we
have only a limited pot we'll pay 30
million marks we can't afford to pay
more um but you divided
so they pitted the jews against the
non-jews
to divide it and then the argument was
what was the ratio in the camp at the
time of liberation and when i was in
poland as a guest of the polish
government in connection with the visit
to these ravensbruck la paz the the
guinea pigs
i got access which nobody else had to
the auschwitz archives
and the chief archivist there gave me
the little bit of cigarette paper which
the then prime minister saran kievic had
smuggled out of the campus the russians
came in listing the ratio of different
nationalities in the camp and it showed
that 95 of them were jews and that made
it possible for us to cut off 10 instead
of 5 for the non-jews and that brought
them in but when it came to the others
they refused to pay aeg the big
electrical company i met with their
representatives in munich which a big
beautiful building
and we finally reached agreement on a
contract and in the contract they said
without recognizing any legal or moral
responsibility
and i said what do you mean no moral
responsibility if you don't want to
recognize any legal responsibility which
is what they all wrote into the contract
if you don't have any moral
responsibility why are you doing it
and he said well that's where we want to
put it and i said why don't you put down
the truth why don't you put down that
you're doing this because you feel
you're being intimidated and blackmailed
by the jews write that into the contract
and i'll buy that i'll sign that
agreement but without recognizing any
legal or moral responsibility i said
that's outrageous why do you pay then
it's a lie to begin with
and uh well we got into quite a heated
argument and my colleague dr anse
kutzenstein who was more sober than i
former german lawyer and israeli very
kind and able man
he calmed me down and we finally signed
the contract with that wording in there
because it was very revealing and when
mr berthold bites the gunner alba
falmeshter the general power of attorney
of uh mr krupp
uh was asked the question on german
television
why
crook didn't pay non-jews
his answer was well you know
the jewish lobby was very active
and the non-jews didn't have that kind
of a lobby so it was an honest statement
but it also revealed
that the germans paid not because they
had a sense of obligation to the jews
it was because they felt they were being
intimidated by the jews and for that
reason they gave as little as possible
they were not concerned with helping the
jews they were concerned with helping
their companies and helping germany and
they were not concerned with saving the
jews they were concerned with saving
germany during the war and the rest of
it is baloney pure and simple and nobody
should believe it
may i correct something
i uh
inadvertently misspoke
uh it was mr spear who was in spandau
prison for 20 years not mr crook crook
was in the sentence for seven years got
out in less time
and was then
allowed to go free with his fortune
thanks to mr mccloy's generosity
um i also
uh made another reference somewhere
where i mixed up the names of spare and
crook
in the connection with the uh
you said that that you said that's that
crook had uh oh yes it was spare it was
spare who had uh
uh
reviewed my manuscript before it was
published and it was spare who wrote on
it ein fishtan agreed so that here's
this leading nazi official confirming
the accuracy of the statement
that i put in my book and the proof that
the german industrialists were lying and
he was in the best position of all to
know were there problems between the the
jewish
survivors who were getting some kind of
compensation however minimal it was and
the non-jews and the international
auschwitz committee headed by langbine
because they were excluded uh there were
no real problems we met with longbine on
occasion but there was no massive
movement because the inmates themselves
were unaware that these negotiations
were taking place and in fact when we
later distributed these funds
we found very often the inmates came and
filed claims when in fact they had not
worked for that company uh or if they'd
worked for that company not a plant
which was authorized to receive
compensation
and we had to engage
on a voluntary basis
uh
persons whom we knew had been there for
a long time and they would form a
screening committee and invite the
claimants in in doubtful cases and try
to confirm
that they had actually been there or not
been there and there were many cases
where the inmate
through
error or through
a moral feeling that what difference
does it make if i worked for krupp or or
schmidt i was the same kind of work in
the same place at the same time the same
beatings and the same starvation why
should he get and not i and marley they
were right
but
we couldn't do anything about it that
was the terms of the contract so we
screened them out and uh always kindly
uh we never you know accused them of
malice or
theft or corruption we said but sorry
you're mistaken uh you have not been
able to establish to our satisfaction
that you worked under the conditions
specified in the contract and we're
sorry we can't pay you what we should
otherwise
so we had a lot of that
i wanted to go back for a second to the
opening statement that you made at the
einsatzgruppen trial when you were 27
years old and then
have you comment on it and talk about
your work for world peace because it
seems to me that those statements
are directly related to everything else
that you started
that you've been doing
you said vengeance is not our goal
nor do we seek merely a just retribution
we ask the court to affirm by
international penal action man's right
to live in peace and dignity regardless
of his race or creed the case we present
is a plea of humanity to law
and towards the end of the statement you
said
we seek here a judgment expressing that
conscience and reaffirming under law the
basic rights of
man um my feelings expressed at that
time have not changed
um i am a lawyer
that's all i ever wanted to be
i felt that
the nuremberg trial and the
einsatzgruppen case in particular
was an opportunity and an obligation to
advance the rule of law
that
[Music]
if it's going to have any significance
it has to have more than merely
executing 22 people for murdering a
million people
that's you cannot compare
there's nothing that could be done to
these defendants which would expiate in
any way the magnitude of a crime of that
size and i struggled with that problem
as a young man
but at that time because it was expected
as a french headline said that our
prosecutor would come in and say i'd
demand their heads je vous de monde
was what some french paper uh falsely
stated as my opening statement it was
never
my opening statement nor that i have
such feelings
um
but it had to have some significance
some permanent significance otherwise
they died for nothing and
the idea of creating a rule of law where
all persons when i talk about
mankind i meant women kind as well
weren't as sensitive as we are now
where all persons could live in peace
and dignity
regardless of whatever their race or
creed might be
and
that idea remained with me
and it remained with me till this day
and
i would say that most of my life not all
of it was dedicated to trying to make
that a reality and there's a certain bit
of madness in that you know when one
human being sets out and he says well
look let's see what we can do to make
this a world in which those conditions
exist
and
when i was about 50 years of age my kids
were already grown and i felt well now i
can
dedicate myself full time to that
because i didn't have to
you know be so concerned about sending
them off to college and meeting all
their expenses and all the rest and i
thought well i'll focus now on that
and i began to
disassociate from my law practice
and devote myself
full-time
by full-time i mean only 50-60 hours a
week uh to uh to those goals
now as a practical matter the way that
worked was i thought well where do i
begin
uh
and i realized that there was need for
an international criminal court
to deal with crimes against humanity
that was the main pitch of my nuremberg
trial crimes against humanity that
humankind has a right to be protected
from this kind of slaughter and abuse
simply because of your race or religion
and so crimes against humanity was the
thing that i was interested in and
in a court to condemn such crimes and
there was no court after nuremberg and
the subsequent trials there was no such
court crimes against humanity were
committed in many places in biafra uh
and and
in vietnam and in all kinds of places
nobody talked about a court nobody
talked about punishing the most
outrageous crime millions of people were
being killed and the international
community was looking the other way
including the jewish community i'm
ashamed to say they didn't care you know
it was not them there was somebody else
very little jewish concern
and
so i began to work on international
criminal court
and
it
the united nations was already working
on that problem ever since nuremberg but
had made no progress and made no
progress because the nations didn't want
it
and
they said that the until they had a
definition of aggression
they uh no use having a court because
aggression is the biggest of all crimes
and they had been fooling around with
the definition of aggression for 30 or
40 years with no progress so i decided
to work on the definition of aggression
first to get that out of the way and
where we go from there is another story
it seemed to me to be it a bit absurd
that the international legal community
was unable to define aggression
i began to work on that problem
when i work on any problem i do it the
same way i begin from the beginning of
time
and read and study everything that's
ever been written or said
and
i began to lobby at the united nations
where there was a special committee
appointed to define aggression and was
going nowhere
and i would go
i got access i obtained a pass to the
united nations i changed several passes
of various kinds
and was able to go to all of the
meetings and i met with the delegates
and i
presented papers for them and i coached
them and i spoke with them and i lobbied
with them and i wrote articles in all
law reviews and things of that kind to
make a long story short they finally
agreed upon a consensus definition of
aggression
an interesting side note i knew it was
coming it was a good friday it was in
1974 i think it was 72.
74.
and i came home
and i said to graduate tomorrow you come
with me to the united nations they're
going to reach a consensus definition of
aggression for the first time in 50
years
it'll be the legal committee the sixth
committee of the united nations special
committee on aggression and i took her
there and sure enough a few minutes it
came it's already been prepared and i we
vote upon a consensus definition of
aggression and i said look around you
we're one of these big halls of the
united nations
nobody was there was in the evening
the two of us were sitting in the
rear section of the uh hall
and i said you see
this entire hall
the only two people who are not paid to
be here are you and me
and uh it was a historic occasion then i
immediately wrote two volume book on
definition of aggression which spelled
out the background of all of this and
this became a classic work on the
definition of aggression then i said ah
now we can go on to the international
criminal court and that obstacle had
been gotten out of the way and they
began to work on a court but they were
getting absolutely nowhere and again i
did the same thing and they wrote a
two-volume book on an international
criminal court which laid out the
history the documents the background the
argumentation for it how you can create
such a court and everything else
that book came out i don't know 1975
it's right after the definition
and nobody read the book and nobody paid
any attention to the book
well i thought well all right so i i
tell them how to do it they're not
interested how do you enforce
international law
so i wrote two volume book on that one
and somebody said why do you keep
writing books in two volumes
i said well because my typewriter is so
high i need some books to sit on and i
need two volumes but of course that was
only a joke it was it was in fact all
the documentation all the history
everything was there
going back you know to ancient days and
it was a very useful tool that's what it
was intended to be it was my notebooks
and when i got through with that still
nobody was paying any attention
i wrote another book common sense guide
to world peace uh i wrote planet hood i
wrote another book on i called in the
russians and we
compared notes with some russian experts
and i kept writing books in article to
speak
and going to the united nations going to
all these meetings keeping abreast of
what was going on trying to influence it
and nothing much was happening and
crimes were being committed everywhere
and sometimes i thought i had gotten the
governments moving in bangladesh when
thousands of women were being raped they
said they were going to set up a court
and i was advising them on that they
didn't pay me for it i was advising them
for it then in the end they said well
let's have reconciliation and forget it
and of course the crimes continued
and uh then something very interesting
happened
yugoslavia
and
in yugoslavia there we had genocide all
over again
before that we had saddam hussein clear
case of aggression
clear case of all kinds of war crimes
clear case including rape pillage murder
and environmental you know depredations
which had not been listed as a crime
before but all kinds of things and the
international community did nothing
and they chased him out but as far as
saddam hussein was concerned
nothing they allowed him to remain and i
was screaming bloody murder everywhere
saying you are encouraging more
criminality you have betrayed half a
million young american people who risked
their lives to go out into that desert
and then you didn't have the courage
to follow through and do what needed to
be done in order to create a more
peaceful world order by punishing those
who are responsible for the crimes
instead you punished innocent civilian
population your sanctions starve them he
doesn't go hungry and i began to scream
and television and radio and every place
i could go not many because most people
are not interested they're interested in
you know scandal and things of that kind
rock stars
football players not interested in
scholars however along came yugoslavia
where genocide now called ethnic
cleansing got very popular
and mass rapes got very popular
and the united states said we can't get
involved we had our fingers were burned
in somalia we don't want to do what we
did in other places in lebanon the
united states government was opposed to
an international court was opposed to
doing anything
but because of this medium
because of television and the
opportunity of the public to see
people get on television and say as i
heard one man say
i
served in seoul he said yes i
raped
dozens of muslim women
but then i cut their throats
because that's what my commander told me
to do
and the women of america
god bless them began to scream do
something
and the u.s government for the first
time said we have to do something what
can we do
the court
let's set up a court we're not going to
send troops let's set up a court
and so they set up
a court for yugoslavia war crimes in
yugoslavia limited to yugoslavia and
limited after 1991 which is of course
preposterous
so happened that when the general
assembly approved the draft statute for
that court i was in geneva at a meeting
of the international law commission i'm
not a member of that commission i was
there doing my usual type of lobbying
but a proud moment was when the statutes
came through on the facts and they're
big things
one of the staff members brought it to
me and said here this is your work
so there are times when there is
progress made it may take a long time
and it may be slow progress and it is
slow progress and it's ridiculous to
have a court limited jurisdiction
limited period of time we need a
permanent international criminal court
and i'm still working on that because
there's this big gap in the
international legal order
and my latest book new legal foundations
for global survival security through the
security council is a comprehensive
bringing together of 20 years of careful
thought and i share that with the public
all of my royalties are given away to
peace groups i will not make a penny on
that book any more than we did with the
book planet hood which was written with
ken kais who incidentally is
quadriplegic and totally ignores it no
penny for him not penny for me that book
is out to educate the public on the need
for planetary thinking
uh if we're going to have a peaceful
world there will be no peace for anyone
anywhere until there is peace everywhere
and that's my conviction
and in this last book i try to lay out
the blueprint specifically including the
security council resolutions that are
needed in order to achieve that goal and
it is feasible and it's feasible without
amending the u.n charter
and i'm afraid to tear up the u.n
charter and start again because i see
the anarchy that comes in places like
the former soviet union and yugoslavia
and it's too dangerous too many people
will die before we can pull the thing
together again so i'm ready to try to
make it work within its existing
framework by interpreting the laws and
by laying out new rules to make the
security council a more democratic and
fairer institution than it is today and
that is the gist of my thinking and of
my new book and now that i'm approaching
the age of 75
i hope the time will come for me to
close my book and say that this is my
effort to create a more humane and more
peaceful world where all may live in
peace and dignity
it's not a matter of patience
it's not a matter of patience it's a
drive it's a calling it's not a job
it's not something that i set out to do
it's something that
happens
uh and it's uh
i cannot it's not something which
requires my patience i have no patience
for anything else
so
i can't explain that
i really can't explain it it may be a
trauma
it may be one of these delayed syndromes
that they write about
but it's harmless i hope
and and i function quite well
ben i wonder if you could read a short
excerpt from one of the letters that you
wrote gertrude your wife when you were
on the war crimes investigating teams
i have one here now um
it's interesting that my wife gertrude
who was then not my wife she was only my
i can't say girlfriend anymore can you i
don't know what's appropriate term she
was my sweetheart my darling it says
here um
she saved all the letters that i wrote
from the front
and including the uh
uh
scenes in the concentration camps as i
came in
many of the camps and all of these
letters were saved by her they're 50
years old
in their original envelopes
at that time you were not allowed to
write where you were you were not
allowed to describe it and i smuggled
these out
by some means which i don't even
remember anymore but i was probably
giving it to some officer who was going
to another country to put it in the
mailbox or something and
so she has them with the envelopes and
with the stamps on them and
all of these that relate to holocaust
have been given to the holocaust
memorial museum and they can be found
there in more detail but here's one
which is i think reasonably typical
it's only the covering note for a very
much longer report
i don't know how many pages the long
report is but much more detail and i say
here this is the case i wrote about long
ago this is dated june 14th 1945. i must
have written about it in
may while the uh
war was still on
i was in the town of stum's ride near
hum germany i know that near the czech
border when liberated french pw's told
me about having to dig a hole by order
of the ss they pointed out the spot
where the hole had been dug
when i saw it it had already been
covered over the old lady at the nearby
farmhouse told me about seeing the ss
hurting a group of weary men into the
woods they were part of the fifteen
thousand who had been marched out of
flossenberg concentration camp headed
for dahao as the american approached at
the end of april
the farmer's wife heard the shots as
they rang out at brief intervals the
farmer and his sons made sworn
statements about how they had covered
the bodies with dirt in order to prevent
disease i took those affidavits from
them
i sent the photographers to the spot and
here you have the results i must have
enclosed pictures
i'm sure i did i'm sure the holocaust
memorial museum has those pictures of
the bodies
that i helped uncover
hope they won't scare you but the
pictures can only give a small
indication of what it actually was like
i just want to get the things off my
hands
use them in any way you like dear and i
hope they won't keep you awake
we'll write a decent letter later
p.s just in case you can't find that
other more detailed letter these
murdered men were political prisoners of
every nationality and were murdered
simply because they appeared to be too
tired to continue the march successfully
the ss beast didn't even wait for these
men to fall they just marched them into
the woods for the slaughter
these were non-jews
jews of course were included as well
so on that happy note
thank you
i thank you
for the opportunity to record this piece
of history and we hope that the next
world will be a better one
i thank you all
thank you so much for everything you've
done not just for this
you're watching american history tv